Three you started at three to ah,
tricky
and we're live.
Hi Julie.
I'm doing that.
What's happening?
We were just talking before this podcast
started at a year.
We were working on your masters in
nonfiction,
shin creative writing,
creative nonfiction.
What does creative nonfiction,
how's that work?
It's actually very encompassing of a lot
of things to think about like memoir or
biography essays especially where a
bunch of Sas,
we're a bunch of nerds.
They pick about I think nine or 10 of us
out of a group of 150 for this program.
And then,
um,
we write a ton of essays and we read so
much.
It's insane.
It's amazing how many female MMA
fighters,
not that this is a knock against male
mma fighters are like really fucking
smart.
Like Rosie Sexton,
you know,
there's like,
there's a ton of them.
You can go down the list.
Yeah.
Peggy Morgan,
she's got,
yeah,
the really intelligent female fighters.
I think that,
um,
I think there's something with mma and
creativity and I think whereas,
because the opportunities maybe haven't
been out there for women as much when it
comes to like,
I guess finding an avenue for that
creativity there,
you know,
they go into other things like academics
and arts and then they find mma and then
they try to do both.
I wonder if it's that,
oh,
I mean,
I think there's probably a bunch of
reason.
Roxanne metaphoric.
That's another one.
She's super smart.
I always wonder if it's like,
maybe it's such an odd thing,
especially when you started,
I mean,
you're a real pioneer in a lot of ways.
you fought Gina Carano in 2007,
10 years ago,
long time ago.
It's crazy when you think about it.
You know,
mma was like nonexistent in the public's
fear back then.
It just wasn't something that people
talked about for women.
But the women that did get into it and
it reached like a professional level,
they have to be like extremely danger.
Daring you,
I mean,
it's a,
it's a kind of a crazy occupation.
It is.
It's,
um,
and I think that those of us who started
back then,
of course,
I'm not knocking the people who are
doing it now because there are
tremendous athletes and the,
you know,
the women going into it now,
but the environment was such that you
had to be really obsessive and I'm sure
that,
you know,
many other female athletes at this time
have that kind of obsessive streak.
But I think at that time,
because we,
I mean,
you know,
we'd scour the internet like mma
underground.
That was,
I was always looking for fights.
It was always trying to find somebody to
find me or the shirt,
og forums,
all that stuff before it got kind of,
yeah,
exactly.
I know.
It's like,
Oh,
who wants to fight?
And he wants to fight me and somebody
say,
I want to fight you.
Like,
yes,
thank you.
I'm so,
I'm so grateful.
It was a weird atmosphere back then.
Yeah,
it was a,
well,
it was people doing it just for the pure
passion of it.
You know,
I got to talk to Jeremy Horn about this.
Jeremy I think has had 150 pro fights,
something crazy like that.
And he was like,
you have to realize like back then we
were doing it because we wanted to do
it.
It would no one was thinking that this
was going to be an avenue for you to be
the next condom or greg or the next
Ronda Rousey.
I mean it didn't,
no,
no.
My,
yeah,
my very first fight,
um,
they videotaped me was for Jeff Osborne
and who can shoot and the video taping
this and what do you want to do at this?
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm going to be in the UFC.
And that was 2004 there and you know,
everybody laughed at me.
I was like,
no,
I'm going to be in the UFC.
Just watch me.
I actually can't believe I did,
but I mean,
I can't believe I,
that was my goal.
That's what,
you know,
that's,
I didn't do well on the UFC,
but it got there you,
I check that one off.
But um,
you know,
it wasn't about being that superstar.
It was about where you would get to
fight,
you know,
what would you,
you would get to do.
And I don't know,
just getting to fight with such a
pleasure,
you know,
just the ABS.
I have a fight.
The excitement you would have,
like I have a fight.
Oh my God,
this is great.
That's a crazy feeling to try to explain
to someone that has never done anything
remotely as dangerous as competing in
MMA.
You know?
Try to explain that to someone.
Like if you were talking to some woman
who's a doctor or a professor or a just
normal job,
you know,
those aren't the most normal.
You don't tell him.
I'm just saying if you were trying to
explain to someone what you want to
fight,
like you want,
you're looking forward to something
that's going to make you terribly
nervous,
you're probably going to want to throw
up right before you go out there.
You're going to be freaking out and then
finally going to be in there doing it.
Yeah,
and it's,
yeah,
I mean it's really,
it's difficult to,
to explain,
I guess maybe ultra marathon runners or
somebody of that kind of different
sphere of,
of expression would maybe understand it.
What you want to run a hundred miles in
the desert or whatever.
You know,
I think that there's,
there's an extreme him and a lot of
people that,
um,
lays pretty dormant,
but when you get into it,
when you find an avenue for it and you
get to explain,
it becomes so addictive and you just
want to keep doing it.
You want,
you can't stop doing it.
Do you also kind of take comfort in the
fact that she's just a few of you out
there like that?
Because I've been really getting it,
this is a really strange thing to get
obsessed with because I'm not really
going to do it,
but I'm,
I'm obsessed with these people that hike
across the country.
Do you know what I'm talking to you
about the Appalachian trail?
Yeah.
I'm having this guy on who has completed
the Appalachian trail and I'm just,
I'm obsessed with these people.
They cut their toothbrushes in half to
save weight.
Like they were one piece of clothing for
like six months.
Like it's nuts.
They bring water filters,
they can find creeks and drink out of
water and they,
these are educated people,
college degrees and they just want to
see if they can walk from Georgia to
Maine.
I think
everybody has that in them to a certain
extent where they just have to push
themselves in some direction.
Although,
you know,
when it comes to those long hikes,
I've also heard from people who have
failed at the Appalachian trail.
You know,
after a certain point you're just
putting one foot in front of the other
and it doesn't mean anything anymore.
Right.
So I think that there's also that,
that sense of burnout,
but those people with that,
that drive to do something with passion,
I think is the perfect word for it that
just want to push beyond what they know
into a different sphere.
Um,
the problem is it does become addictive
and your body or your mind can't always
keep up with it.
Yeah.
And there's a thing
that happens to people when they become
addicted to things where it overwhelms
them.
It becomes all consuming.
Yeah.
You know,
so you're all consuming.
Thing is trying to run.
You did a hundred miles,
now you got to run 200 miles like,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
You have to be faster this time.
Now you've got to win.
Like it's,
it's a strange compulsion to push
yourself to almost like experience
yourself.
It's almost like regular life in its
placid.
Vibration is frustrating.
It's just,
it's just,
there's not enough,
there's not enough tension.
There's not enough excitement.
There's not enough you need like,
wow.
I mean that's,
that's how we settled a new world.
Right?
That's how like that's,
I mean that's how mountains are,
are,
are climbed.
Our summative,
that's how we get to space is because
you just,
there's something in human nature that's
so precious that you just have to keep
pushing it.
It's a collective feeling.
But then,
you know,
there's some individuals out there who
just stand a little bit apart or just an
a maybe a different playground and they
just want to keep pushing and pushing
and pushing and they want to be the
ones.
And that's how we achieve.
The thing about mma though,
it's like you have to,
I guess,
balance that pushing with preserving
your physical health,
especially someone who's as smart as
you,
it's gotta be an interesting sort of an
act of balancing act because you're,
yeah.
I,
yeah,
excuse me for talking real.
Please.
Go ahead.
I always get all excited and talk.
No,
I'm,
I,
my body's a rack now.
Like I'm,
there's no way I could ever compete in
MMA again.
What's going on?
Oh,
my neck is out.
Um,
I had shoulder surgery in 2012 and
something happened with my neck and it
never healed correctly.
So what is it?
No,
I've never getting Mris.
I hate it.
I don't like being in a tube like that.
It makes me really nervous.
So you just,
yeah,
so I just deal with it.
I mean,
just massage and stuff.
But,
um,
uh,
my knees are,
are pretty bad.
I get SCIATICA.
Like I understand that I don't,
I retired kind of young I guess,
but I understood that it was the time I
need it to because things were not going
to function in my body on the level that
they needed to.
And my mind wasn't in a place where it
would push beyond that.
When you competed professionally for
what,
10 years more?
Yeah,
nine years.
I'm like,
yeah,
I mean I was,
I've been doing martial arts since I was
four,
so that's a lot of years and there's a
lot of years.
That's 32 years.
Um,
but you know,
I like actually competing.
Like I knew that that wasn't giving me,
I knew that at my last fight,
like before I walked out there,
I told Greg Jackson,
I said,
this is it.
I'm done.
And he was like,
okay.
Which,
and I was like,
is he going to try it before you went
out there?
Oh,
I was so sick.
I got,
yeah,
I had food poisoning.
It was weird.
It was when I fought batchko hair.
And,
um,
anyway,
you know,
stressing about batch rolling your yell
a little bit,
a little bit.
Know there's always that you always had
that thing where it's like I won that
fight.
Come on,
right?
Yeah.
Throw me a bone.
I won that fight and stop wiggling your
butt.
But you know,
whatever.
She does her thing.
She's been very successful with the
batch brand.
Um,
but uh,
no,
I had food poisoning.
I don't know.
Back then,
you know,
you were still,
you're still like to do ivs and stuff.
So I had ivs and I thought they worked
well and I think I ate something wrong
or something weird,
but I woke up the next day.
Well I have a history of a lot of,
of shitting myself a lot.
I don't know.
Well yes,
that has happened.
Yes.
It's what I'm known for is shitting
myself in Russia.
But um,
yeah,
it was a good one right in front of
Putin.
I'm really,
you show yourself in front of Putin.
Well,
okay,
I'll,
I'll backtrack to that story cause it's,
it's my favorite.
It's my mma story story.
Yeah,
no,
it was my first fight under Greg
Jackson.
It was in 2007 was after the Toronto
fight.
And I,
um,
I had met him at that fight.
He enjoyed these in your,
and Keith Jardine,
some of these people and they were
really kind to me and I had another
fight in Saint Petersburg with bodog a
couple months later and my corner man
couldn't make it.
I was in Indiana at the time.
Was that the undercard of Fader and Matt
Lindland?
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Um,
so I,
uh,
I called up this nice guy.
I didn't know he was famous.
All I cared about was women competing in
the sport.
I didn't care about the guys very much.
You know,
I liked tough,
was interesting,
but it really didn't do anything for me.
I would watch fights if I could,
but I couldn't afford paper.
It was like,
well,
they're not letting me in that show,
but bodog did you know these other shows
that were,
you know,
Internet based,
and I call up this nice guy,
Greg Jackson,
and I'm just like,
Hey,
uh,
would you be interested in coronary me
for a fight?
And he's like,
well,
why don't you come here and train?
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm one of those.
And it turned out no,
he uses really nice guy who gave me a
job and a place to live when I moved
there.
But,
um,
no,
but,
um,
so I,
I drove out to albuquerque and I was
there for three days and I realized I
was never going to leave.
Like,
this is it,
this is my team,
this is my home,
like left everything behind me,
which wasn't maybe very nice to my
boyfriend,
but you know,
boyfriends.
Yeah.
I mean it was my fight career.
Like that's what counted Indiana.
Yeah.
Just outside of Indianapolis.
And Albuquerque is a,
it's not like you're moving to some like
boulder or even looking at the rocky
mountains or something.
I mean,
there are beautiful mountains,
but no,
it's not.
It's not,
uh,
maybe,
pleasure,
destination Turkey,
the Jackson camp there.
It's a little odd.
It's an odd,
it would have been a difficult move
without the Jackson Campaign for sure.
Yeah.
You know,
the crack needles everywhere.
He's done a great job of fostering like
this amazing sense of community though.
Yeah.
He really,
yeah,
there they are.
Tremendous men.
Like I,
I feel like I did a lot of great stuff
in my life.
Like I'm proud of the things I've done,
but I think that I was also surrounded
by people who really guided me well,
who really like,
you know,
like going back to school and stuff like
that after my career,
you know,
these are,
this is the influences of people who
were just like,
they care about the people on their
team.
They care about who they surround
themselves with.
But I didn't know any of that.
I just kind of showed up.
And first,
you know,
I drive to the gym and Greg says,
Oh,
follow me back to my place.
And immediately I back into the dumpster
at the gym.
I'm a total Klutz.
Um,
but no,
he came out to Russia with me for that
fight and I want to impress him because
I didn't realize until it was in that
gym,
I was just like,
oh,
this is going to be like my sense I like
this is the,
this
is like,
I feel like a Samurai and this is like
the person I want to,
I forgot what that relationship is
called.
This is the person I really want to lead
me and guide me.
He's my leader and I wanted to impress
him so badly.
And that fight,
first thing she does right away,
it was against Yulia bears a coveage
first thing she does punch me in the
nose,
just shatters my nose,
blood everywhere.
I was like,
great,
this is again.
And it was right after the Toronto
fight.
So it was like I was used to losing
which,
and you never want to get in that space
of being used to losing.
But somehow I clicked and you know,
I,
I did pretty well in the fight and I
ended up getting a mounted triangle on
her and finishing with strikes.
Um,
in between rounds,
another corner,
men put cold water in the back of my
neck.
And I thought that I just started,
I thought it was a Fart,
but
turns out,
and this poor girl mounted triangle,
no less,
this poor girl,
I had no idea of this.
Oh yeah.
So they grab us,
they put us on his bus,
I'm still in my
fight,
closes of blood,
can limit gloves on and they just put us
on a bus separate me and Amanda Buckner
from our corner men and everything
because we'd want our fights and they
take us to this palace and I cannot
remember who's pals,
Alexander or something like it was in
Saint Petersburg and it was beautiful
gold.
Damn.
I was going to silk and just,
I'm in my clothes and I'm like,
what is that smell?
And I was like,
I'd seen a guy puking backstage cause
you know,
cause of a headshot.
And I was like,
I must've like rolled in it or stepped
in and I smell so bad.
And John Claude van Damme randomly walks
up to us.
I mean it was just like,
you know,
bay doors here,
John Claude van Damme,
this and that.
Like just weird and surreal already head
trauma going on with me.
Like not really in my right mind.
Right.
And I just,
it was so weird to be like smelling
myself and being like,
God,
I stepped in Puke.
I'm sorry Mister Van dam like that.
I smell so badly.
That's so crazy too because you got
punched in the nose if you smelled it
through,
your nose is fucked up.
I remember being on the bus and looking
around going to say Miami perfume or
anything and other people are allowed to
shower,
but I was allowed to swing bat.
Right.
So I was right after
put you on a bus,
didn't tell me where I was going and
that's a good way to get staff.
No kidding.
It was really gross.
I've been lucky with staff,
but yes.
So we,
I ended up,
you know,
going to the restroom,
looking at the shit kicked all over it.
Oh,
it was like,
it must have been in between rounds.
It's disgusting.
It's like there's no trashcan.
It's like silk and gold in this
beautiful palace
stuff.
So I just like take my panties off and
just like roll them up and shove him
behind the toilet.
Black Lace Thong Vladimir Putin.
That was mine.
I want to,
I want it back.
No,
I don't want it back.
2000.
It was 10 years ago and that's crap.
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
and then I just go back out there and
it's like Berlusconi was like hitting on
me and,
and,
and like trying to pick me up and he's
like,
Hey,
can I be your boyfriend tonight?
And I'm just like,
what?
Sing it through a translator.
So it was so,
and I'm like,
I smell like shit.
Like I couldn't,
it was like,
you are a dirty motherfucker.
Like Putin comes,
you know,
puts his arm around me,
Dan.
I'm just like
weird as hell.
That wasn't,
it was just like I shit myself in front
of foreign dignitaries in another
country.
Wow.
That's probably my favorite MMA story.
How surreal was it to meet booton?
I had no idea at the time,
like what a big deal,
but that's usually,
I stumbled into things without knowing,
which is probably best because I'm a
very nervous person.
Like I'm a very intense person and so
being there and just having had the
fight,
I dunno.
Like when I think about it,
I'm just like,
I'm sorry Donald Trump,
but your hookers pissing on you thing.
Sorry Dude.
Then done and it's been done better.
Yeah.
Evil.
Wow then.
And I had no idea.
No idea.
What he looked different then.
Yeah.
I was really blonde.
No,
he,
he did look different,
didn't he?
Yeah.
Wow.
That was when he had taken a break from
being the dictator,
right?
Yeah.
I think he was prime minister at that
time or something,
but then he just went right back into
power.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
So strange.
Oh,
just being in that kind of atmosphere
and sweatpants and fight close.
I'm just not going to tap out was still
cool.
Oh yeah.
I love them.
They were like,
they put me on their show.
Like they took such good care of me.
Ah,
yeah.
I mean it's a good,
the tap out stories,
like a good cautionary tale for like
beating a brand in the ground to the
point where you gotta like go up to some
people and go,
hey man,
you can't wear shit.
Oh,
I know plenty though.
It's so
weird.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing like branding and all
of that.
That's a huge,
like now I'm becoming so aware of it
because I know other writers,
that's a really big avenue because if
you think about Donald Trump,
I mean he's become president because of
his brand.
Right?
There's a lot of ways.
Yeah.
I'm stealing one of the other writers
ideas right now,
so I shouldn't be saying that,
but yeah.
But I mean really,
he's a brand and that brand was so
successful.
It convinced a bunch of people that
that's what was going to be best for our
country.
And it was a brand.
It was a commercial.
There's that,
but I think there's also a real lack of
substantial options.
It wasn't like there was any one
compelling person that was next to him.
I know I was such a Bernie Fan.
I really thought that he was outside of
the mold.
Um,
but everybody is a politician.
I mean it's,
he's a boy.
He's the best example I think of a guy
who really isn't beholden to any special
interest groups.
But I think what he offered and what
trump offers as well is that they're
outside of the system in some way.
Trump appears to be like way more inside
the system news giving on to be,
but at least it's shakes up this
ridiculous.
They have this like really cryptic sort
of way of doing business and bizarre way
of intermingling money and influence and
politics and putting it all together and
it's just something has got to come
along to let people know like,
Hey,
this system sucks.
It doesn't represent us.
It's foolish.
It's ancient.
It was made up when people used to write
with
feathers.
We really need a better system.
I agree.
I totally agree.
And you know,
like this entire election,
everything about it has pushed me into
being like,
no man,
I'm a straight up socialist like an I
used to resist that title.
Or you say no,
I'm liberal and I'm this and that.
No,
no,
I'm a socialist.
I don't actually even think that I agree
with some of the liberal things that
have been espoused during all of this.
Like I think that we are at a point and
evolved people,
you know,
in,
in such a respect that we have to take
care of each other and it has to be
mandated from a bigger power because we
don't take care of each other otherwise
no socialist.
Like in what way?
How do you define it?
You don't,
my idea of socialism,
of course we'd never fly,
but it's basically a bit,
we all pay into a system that pays us
back.
We all,
you know,
we all work for the common man and I
know that that's not it.
It never works.
But in my mind that's the way it should
be,
that we should all be working for the
guy next to us.
What would work great if people like
you,
if they're hardworking,
smart people.
Well,
I mean I have student loans out now.
Well that's another discussion.
Totally.
But I think student loans are
disgusting.
I think what they're doing by
subsidizing education and making people
pay these ridiculous rates,
not only that,
if you go bankrupt,
it doesn't matter.
You still have to pay your student
loans.
You can never get away from that.
A single other business venture that you
get into and you would consider
investing in your education and possibly
a future as some sort of a business
venture,
business slash educational adventure.
You're not you all that money period.
You're not getting away from it.
You,
they'll drag you to the ground.
They will.
You know,
and I would say that the thing that it
does have going for is the interest
rates a little bit better than like
credit cards and cars and stuff should
be zero interest rate should be,
I mean education should be,
in my opinion,
it should be for every like people
should be educated.
It should be.
And I'm with you.
Yeah,
I think it should be free.
I 100 and I think it should be available
to anyone at anytime in your life.
I don't think you should be like 43
years old and you can't go back to
school again.
I mean,
I don't think it should be able to go
back to school at anytime.
It shouldn't just be for 18 year old
people right out of high school.
It should be for anybody that really
wants to learn and educate.
Yeah.
I actually think 18 year old people
right out of high school should be
taking some time off to actually see the
world before they go back into this
because if you don't choose to approach
your education seriously,
you're going to have a really hard time.
I'm not a big fan of rigid systems
either.
I'm not a fan of like this really
regimented,
go through four years of high school,
go through four years of college,
then you do this,
then you get a job.
It's dirt,
you're 30 you should have a child.
I just don't buy any of it.
I just think it's,
there's so many different people out
there with so many different dreams and
aspirations and interests.
We were,
it's so rigid.
And when kids see this rigid path in
front of them,
first of all,
it gives them anxiety.
That's what it used to give me as to see
people that were going to college and
getting degrees,
getting jobs.
I'd get anxious because it was like,
I'm not like them.
I feel like a loser.
I feel like an outcast,
you know?
And I think that if we made education
free and made it available to people,
like I just don't think,
I think that if we could spend the
amount of money that we spend on the
military,
not that we should cut back the amount
of money,
but there's gotta be that same amount of
money or in the neighborhood of that
same amount of money that could go
towards infrastructure that could go
towards education,
that could go towards impoverished
communities.
There's like zero effort made to build
this country back up.
Well,
I would say yeah,
and looking at the proposals on deck
right now,
the little that's being used for it,
like the any and stuff like that,
that's being taken off now.
I mean the what?
The National Endowment for the arts,
stuff like that.
That gives actual like people and
artists who maybe don't fit the mold but
actually have a,
a venture going for them that they could
be successful with if they got some sort
of funding or support.
I agree with that,
but I've been to the La County Museum of
art,
that Lacma thing.
Jesus Christ,
I'll take you there.
If you want,
you'll fucking,
you want to throw punches at people that
they have the most ridiculous like
modern art.
Like this is a video of people playing
catch.
This is art and I'm not kidding.
Well,
you know,
it's all subsidized
very hard time.
I actually love modern art if I know
what's going on.
But if I don't,
then I feel like I'm,
I'm just not getting it and I don't
understand what's happening.
But I,
yeah,
I do think that,
I think not pushing art on people,
I shouldn't say pushing our,
but I,
I guess providing opportunities for art
for people and not just art isn't
painting or sculpture,
but I mean like writing and literature
and it's the ways I do think that the
rigid educational system or you just
like,
you do this,
you do this.
Some people's brains just aren't wired
that way.
Right.
But there are other avenues for them to
be creative and define themselves.
And like I found with mma,
I mean I was prelaw and then my last
semester of college I was like,
I don't want to,
I don't want to go to law school.
I don't want to do this.
I want to be professional fighter.
Now
what would compel you to do that?
Because you,
you have this long history of martial
arts,
you got into martial arts,
you said when you're four,
five,
four,
four taekwondo.
Yeah.
And so you had,
when did you first compete?
Did you compete in taekwondo tournament?
Right.
Did I did,
um,
when I was a teenager I did a lot of the
like the Nazca circuit and the um,
international sport car,
whatever those,
so point karate.
Yeah,
I did a lot of point karate.
You can tell from my fighting cause it
was always stick at my chin out.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I,
I did a lot of sport karate and I was
very anxious to be competitive.
Um,
one of my friends,
I went back to the,
to the final hook and shoot a couple
weeks ago and one of my friends Darrell
nearer used to train with me.
And he,
he was,
um,
he said,
don't you remember when you were 15 or
you're running around the gym just
asking people to punch you in the face
because they,
you weren't allowed to punch in the face
in some of these tournaments and you
wanted to know if you could keep
fighting.
Like I wanted to know if I could keep
If I got punched in the face,
I was going quit bold to hit you and
training so that you could see if you
can keep going.
Yeah.
And then I had my nose severely broken
where I had to have surgery on it.
Um,
and after that,
that's when I decided to be a
professional fighter.
After the surgery,
I should have probably waited.
But how'd you get your nose broken?
Initially?
Spin.
Hook,
kick.
Oh Geez.
Yeah,
it was like over here.
Yeah.
That's a bad one.
But I mean,
now it's like,
it's been broken like seven or eight
times now.
Like I'd love to get it fixed again,
but I'm not sure that my student health
insurance covers that.
So
does your septum work or is it,
yeah,
I can't breathe out of the left side.
What I found out though was really
disturbing was that your ears like how
they calcify and become cauliflower ear.
Your nose does that too.
Oh,
I can believe that.
Yeah.
So the inside of your nose can develop
all these hard calcified areas where
blood is sort of pulled in.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I had to get mine scraped out and they,
they cut out,
I think they're called the turbinates,
these,
these big lumps in there and they kind
of cut them down to open up the path and
then they shoved splints in there and
separate it.
Like it mixed,
it makes the whole wider.
Making the whole wider is not always a
good thing.
But I would say for a nose it's,
yes,
yes and yes.
Sorry,
I'm kind of pervy.
Um,
yeah,
no,
that's um,
I,
I would love to have my nose fixed,
but it is kind of helps you breathe.
Like it helps you sleep if your nose is
a big thing.
I,
mine was fucked up till I was 39 I
think,
or 40 and then I finally got it fixed
and I was like,
I can't believe I lived like this my
whole life with a fucked up stuffed up
nose all the time.
More clearly.
My cardio is better,
everything's better.
When I didn't,
I just was a mouth breather.
Like literally a mouth breather.
Yeah.
There's a lot of fighters that are like
that.
You talk to them,
he kind of,
you hear that in their voice,
how they have that thing going on with a
nasal when you know like,
Oh,
you're all clogged up man.
Like I always wonder what the
relationship between fighters and like
sinus medication is a lot.
Yeah.
I was gonna say like,
I,
I still take it all the time just to,
you know,
just to be able to function.
Otherwise Shit's addictive.
Very addictive.
Like what does it Afrins yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're making me think right now.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing.
That stuff,
it makes your nostrils dilate and it
opens them up,
but when you stop taking it all clamps
down feels like even tighter.
Right.
Yeah.
Not Good.
A lot of good therapy for it.
Yeah.
A lot of guys stuff that stuff up their
nose.
Yeah.
Though the body is just not meant to
take the kind of abuse.
You were good.
You were detailing.
Your neck is fucked up,
your knees are fucked up.
My shoulder is still pretty weak.
The,
that fixed my labor on it happened in
the tate fight.
I think it was tearing before that fight
because I always had a lot of shoulder
pain.
But I've had shoulder pain on both sides
a lot.
But um,
during the tate fight,
I remember throwing a left hook or
something and just below what the hell
happened.
My labor was torn all the way through,
but I had this weird genetic thing
called a Buford complex,
which that's an hilarious name for
something,
but it's like a thick intendance.
So it was holding my arm up so I didn't
know that it was actually torn all the
way through.
It wasn't like limp,
but I do remember like not all of a
sudden not being able to base on my left
side and be like,
Whoa,
what's going on here?
But during the fight that was happening.
So did you get that fixed?
That's what the surgery was for.
But it was,
it was a really intense surgery.
I didn't think it was gonna be that big
of a deal cause I hear about people
going to get their knees scoped and
stuff like that,
but I couldn't get out of bed for a
week.
Like I had to have,
my mother had to come
take care of me and I was like,
you know,
it was 32 years old.
I was like,
this is embarrassing,
but I couldn't actually get out of bed
and move and I ended up having a bad
reaction to the medication and yeah,
that was,
that was a good time.
Time,
surgeries down.
It is.
And what we're saying that the human
body is just not designed for combat
sports.
It just,
after a while everyone's sorta gives
out.
That's why when you see a guy like Dan
Henderson still throwing down whatever,
he was like 46 years old,
have you seen Dan walk?
He walks like he's made out of wood,
you know,
walks like he's got no flexibility.
Then all of a sudden he's in the cage.
He just comes alive.
It's crazy.
Something about that.
Greg always called me the Lucille ball
of him or me because he said that I was
just the clumsiest person he'd ever met.
Like I would just like,
I would trip over every,
I fell down all the time,
but he said,
but when you were fighting you actually
something like use that phrase came
alive.
He said you,
you would actually move like you were
supposed to be moving.
So I do think that maybe the human
body's not meant to take punishment in
combat sports,
but I think we're also built to fight in
a lot of ways.
I mean we've been fighting for years.
It's,
it really is like,
it's Cliche,
but it is kind of in our DNA to scrap.
It has you just,
it's shot just not in your DNA to do it
all the time and stay alive.
Right.
And to sweat your body down to this
certain part and then go here and then,
you know.
Yeah,
let's talk about that because that is
the,
one of the most disturbing things it's
happening lately.
Uh,
all these fights that are falling apart
because people are cutting weight and
cutting so much weight that they're
literally on death's door,
mean whack to the hen and Barao fight
when he was supposed to fight Tj
dillashaw and fell asleep like,
and banged his head off the wall like to
just a couple weeks ago,
the Habib number,
good madoff,
Tony Ferguson fight gets called off,
which is one of the biggest fights of
the year.
And for fans,
it's just so disappointing because we
were so looking forward to that fight.
What do you think could be done about
that as a professional,
as a professional
and as a commentator?
Let's say it was paid to do commentary
for Invicta.
I know it was also the matchmaker,
so I was actually,
uh,
I stepped down from that one.
I backed up and went back to school,
so I'm no longer the INVICTA matchmaker,
but part of my job was I had this really
regimented checking the girls wait twice
a day,
I should say the fighters wait,
but I'm a girl too,
so I can say girl,
but you know,
I would check their weight twice a day
and I had them text me their weight and
I'd be like,
okay,
I need you to send me a picture of what
you're weighing on your scale right now
and compare it to this.
Like I was,
I was kind of a bitch,
but I didn't want fighters missing
weight on my watch.
The problem was they were still going to
Ms.
Wade anyway.
It's eight is there's something archaic
about it.
It's not,
it needs to change I think more weight
classes.
You said that before.
I think more weight classes is a really
good idea.
Yeah.
I feel like every 10 pounds yeah.
Is more than reasonable.
I mean,
boxing is way better and way more
options.
Yeah.
I think every,
every six pounds almost would be,
although that's a lot more divisions.
But I mean,
there's so many people who want
activity.
There's so many people who want to
fight.
I think for women in more importantly,
because when you're talking about six
pounds,
you're talking about a greater
percentage of body weight for a lighter
person.
And when you're talking about 10 pounds
for a heavyweight,
it's like they take a shit.
It's 10 pounds.
You know those giant people like Francis
and Ghana.
Yeah.
Look,
I could probably lose 10 pounds in three
minutes if you want it to his shit.
There's so much surface area to sweat
from.
Yeah.
So massive.
But when you talking about mighty mouse,
10 pounds is a giant amount of weight.
It seems like you want to own j check,
you know,
like one 15 so yeah.
Oh,
I can't wait to see her at 25 but,
um,
I'm really eight.
Is she going to go?
I don't know,
but I'm hoping,
I'm hoping.
I hope she have a hard time to make 15 I
don't know.
I know that she said
she's expressed an interest at fighting
at one 25 which makes me think that one
15 like I don't,
I've met her maybe twice,
so I've never had a lengthy discussion
with her.
She's so bad ass.
I know.
I,
every time she fights I just get so
excited.
She's so far Roche's I know.
She's so ferocious.
Like I'll watch that a fight with her
and Jessica pinay again.
It's like good Lord.
Yeah.
Like when she smells blood and she
starts attacking is smashing with
elbows.
Like she's one of the scariest people in
the sport now and it's beautiful isn't
it?
They get her off you,
you can't get her off right at the end
of her punches and yeah,
she knows exactly what to do with
renaming everything every,
so she's so technical and she's just so
goddamn aggressive,
you know?
Poof.
Technical,
aggressive,
ferocious.
She gives really cookies and ship before
she beats her head.
Yeah.
I love that.
That that entertainment side of it was
never something I captured myself.
Like I didn't have that little niche
sort of.
But when I see fighters do that,
like her who can be the full package,
you can destroy an opponent and make the
fans look forward to just watching her
walk onto a stage.
I love that.
I'm just like,
well that's really who she is,
you know?
I mean,
she's not,
she's not faking it.
Yeah.
Who she is.
And when we talk about branding and
stuff like that,
you kind of wonder who falls into the
category of staying who they are as a
brand,
as a fighter.
Who,
who creates something for themselves and
how much of that is actually authentic
or how much they try to pretend.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
And when you do fake it,
everybody sort of sees it,
you're faking it and it comes off gross
and they get mad at you.
Right.
A guy like conor,
you know like that famous press
conference where Jeremy Stevens calls
him out and he goes,
who the fuck is that guy at?
The speed that he has is natural.
I mean,
it is who he is.
He just knows how to do it.
And so when he does it,
it's effortless.
But when some people try to just look so
goofy,
it's just,
oh,
it's worse.
People want to see you lose when you do
that.
Yeah.
Does it,
does it,
it's,
it comes as inauthentic and it's the
last weird demand that we have as fans.
Cause I,
I don't consider myself a fighter
anymore.
I'm a fight fan now,
but we have this demand for the fighters
to be authentic when they're fighting.
But also when they present themselves,
they have to be themselves somehow.
Or we call them fake or we call it,
you know,
it's like,
it's,
we have a lot of demands on fighters.
Well,
you're putting them under this massive
microscope.
I mean,
you're seeing someone,
when you see two fighters go to war,
you're seeing their souls bared out.
Yeah.
I mean you,
you see so much in what they're capable
of.
Like how the,
the capable of focusing,
pushing themselves,
what they've to discipline themselves
to get ready physically.
I mean,
you could see that,
that you see them express themselves
with their endurance,
like talking about mighty mouse again.
Like you see what amount of work that
guys put in in the gym.
When you see him in the fifth round,
moving a thousand miles an hour and not
even breathing heavy.
It's like there's an expression in that
like you're,
you're seeing something that this guy is
like showing you everything he's got.
He's showing,
showing you his full care.
Yeah.
And he's showing,
there's that click that happens with
some fighters where they're getting
beaten down and all of a sudden they
turn it around me.
She takes a great example of that.
Like,
you know,
and her fight with holly,
like she kicked my ass too.
What the arm bar.
You know,
she,
she turns it around.
Something happens in there and you can
see that that's the warrior thing that
has one actual wars in people where
they've,
you know,
like,
I don't know,
it makes me think of Henry the fifth a
little bit,
you know,
like those moments where we are
outnumbered,
this is going to suck.
I'm losing,
everything's going against me.
All right,
here I go.
I'm still going to keep pushing.
And it's like,
you know,
it's like moments like that if you can
look at fighting from,
I guess you don't take fighting
personally.
Maybe,
I don't know how to explain it by taking
it personally.
But if you can invest yourself in those
moments of glory for another person,
did you get inspired?
You get really turned on to the,
to the whole sport and you really
understand and you can see the human.
Is that easier for you to do now that
you've retired than it was to do while
you're competing?
Did you like compare yourself against
those goals?
Oh,
too much.
I'm the most,
I am a terrible person and I think I was
just,
I mean,
you know,
I,
I think mentally I defeated myself more
than I ever did physically.
Like I,
you know,
I,
but yeah,
I always compared myself against other
people and it was,
it was like,
oh my gosh,
this person's doing this,
this,
this.
I'm not getting that.
I'm not doing that.
I've got to go this direction.
And the,
um,
the pressure I think on female fighters
and it wasn't exactly an outright
pressure to to know,
be sexy or be hot or something like
that.
And then I tried that so hard when I
first started fighting.
Like I took the nude pictures and I
tried to be the sexy girl and I just
could not pull it off.
You could see in my face,
I'm just like,
doofy girl,
you know,
I didn't have that.
Like,
um,
I'm a huge fan of sex and sexuality and
how people want to express it.
It's amazing.
But for me it just had nothing to do
with combat.
Right.
And so the,
the fighters,
the female fighters who could combine
that,
to me it was just,
it was,
I was befuddled.
I was like,
how do they do that?
How do they put that together like that
and still,
you know,
feel tough or still feel ferocious?
Because I mean,
sex is ridiculously fun and sexuality is
like awesome,
but it's also,
to me,
it's not punching people in the face.
And so it was,
and I would always compare myself to,
oh,
I should do that.
I should do that,
you know,
but I can't do that.
It's just inauthentic.
And I think,
I dunno,
to me,
authenticity is just like weird,
huge part of my life that I'm trying to
study with my writing and stuff.
But it's,
it's,
it's funny how,
um,
I would see them just like karate hottie
for example,
like she came into the gym,
I'm into Jackson.
Shorter.
Yeah.
Michelle waterson.
Yeah,
yeah.
Michelle don't know.
Yeah,
we call her nuts or peanut,
but yeah,
Tina.
Yeah,
because she's so little.
Um,
but she,
um,
when she came to the gym,
she was just like little hooters model.
I was like,
who the fucking system?
You know what?
I almost conard like Hickman.
And um,
then she,
I had a black eye when we were sparring
the first time.
Then she gave me another black guy,
like right away,
the first time sparring just,
Bam,
kicked me right in the face and it was
just like,
oh,
I like her.
But I was also like,
I had these hangups about it because I
was so uncomfortable with that sort of
marketing and that way of presenting
yourself.
And also women weren't in the UFC then,
you know,
our opportunities were so weird and so I
would,
I would question people who would push
that side of themselves so much and then
not I'm the fighter woman,
I'm going to do this.
You know what I'm saying?
Exactly.
Is My space then,
which is embarrassing.
But,
and then um,
it's funny cause I had this tension with
her because I was like,
I don't want to market myself in that
direction.
It's not who I am exactly.
When it comes to mma.
And then,
um,
of course greg sense that there was an
uncomfortableness between us and he took
us up to the top of the mountain and
made us run sprints until we were crying
and holding onto each other and became
sisters.
Like it was just like,
he was just like,
all that's bullshit.
You are sisters,
your training partners is,
you're here for each other.
And it was amazing.
It was just like an something clicked in
my mind where I was just like,
oh yeah,
she can promote herself however the fuck
she wants to.
Yeah,
exactly.
She's [inaudible] that's how she is.
That's who she is.
She was a model like that.
That was her profession before this.
So it,
it,
it made a lot more sense to me when I
could step back out of what the boxes
that I had placed myself under.
The container's not necessarily boxes
cause it can feel closed in,
but the containers that I was
comfortable working within for myself or
at the same for the person next to me.
And so,
you know,
it taught me to have a little bit more
respect for people who want to combine
everything the way they want to combine
it.
I think there's a natural inclination to
try to shoot down potential rivals or
potential,
you know,
you're looking at people and you're
trying to pick apart what they do.
I mean,
in a lot of ways when you're a fighter,
you have predatory instincts.
I mean,
you must,
when you're sizing up a pewter opponent,
there's,
there's no way you're not looking at
things they do wrong or things that you
think you can exploit.
Or maybe,
you know,
maybe she doesn't work hard enough or
maybe she misses,
wait because her disciplines off.
And you start,
you start looking for holes in their
game and you're going to,
you're going to do that with a rival in
the gym as well.
Of course you are an eight.
You know,
I wouldn't even go so far to say we were
rivals is I was 30 pounds heavier than
her,
so I was just a bully.
But,
but you know,
the truth of matter is also because
especially the early terrain of women in
the sport,
when there was another woman who came
into the gym,
this can either be your best training
partner other or ever,
or it could be somebody coming in here,
you know,
to pick up,
you don't know.
And I'm think men look at the gym that
way too.
I think that they,
they size each other up in the gym with
a new partner coming in and stuff like
that.
And it's interesting because it sounds
so sexist when I say it,
but it's also,
I don't want to lie,
sit here and lie to you and say,
I think that,
you know,
like I,
when other women would come into the
gym,
I would be like,
Yay.
You know,
that evolved over time and especially
because the atmosphere that greg created
there was incredible.
Like I was the first mma girl really in
that gym.
And then,
you know,
and then Michelle was there and then
other people and now it's like there's a
huge women's team over there.
What was it like to be sparring with men
when you were the first woman there to
be doing most of your training with men
and then going in there fighting women?
They were all sizes,
but you know,
I'll be honest,
I think training with women is important
if you're fighting women.
I think that there's a different kind of
intensity and flexibility,
um,
in body types.
And I don't know that that's completely
across the board,
but I did find it better to have female
sparring partners.
And I was very fortunate in that Holly
Holm was at the gym boxing and she could
kick box and she knew how to sprawl.
So you know,
I was still getting sparring with,
with women there and Jodie Esquibel,
uh,
she,
um,
man,
she was fighting at one oh five.
And I remember Keith had me spa her for
10 rounds and she dropped me twice and
one oh five or I have terrible chin.
Like I would just say just box like this
all the time.
But I used to eight karate style.
Oh,
I know.
So hard to get out of that.
I had a really good job.
I was rarely knocked out,
but it was the jaw that I put in front
of people constantly.
It's always like,
come on,
hit me.
Did you ever think about doing
professional boxing?
I did.
I thought about it.
Um,
especially,
you know,
when,
cause there was a quite,
quite a few female boxers in that gym
and I thought it would be an interesting
thing to do,
but I just never took that path.
I was an,
I was a pretty decent boxing sparring
partner.
Like,
I learned how to imitate,
you know,
their opponents and stuff.
But yeah,
I think I was always better in the gym
that I actually wasn't competition.
Now,
throughout your career,
did you worry at all about head trauma?
Did you worry about the consequences of
until after?
Not Til after it.
Until after.
Why,
why after?
Cause you didn't want to think about it
or was he conscious decision and I think
you have that mentality.
You can be anyone in anything,
even your own body.
Right.
So it was like I'm not going to let that
kind of negativity into my life if I get
knocked out,
whatever,
you know.
But my last fight I do remember,
um,
my jaw was out a little bit.
I had like somebody just adjust my job
cause I kept getting dropped in the
sparring for my last fight and I was
just like,
oh this sucks.
[inaudible] you got your jaw.
Yeah.
He was like,
yeah,
I dunno there was a chiropractor on hand
and I don't know how legit it wasn't,
it wasn't legit.
He seems like a really nice guy.
He was an Ortho therapist and he said,
your jaws offline.
And then he like did some kind of thing
and I stopped getting dropped,
which was nice.
But I don't really jive.
It doesn't.
So I don't know how much of that was
psychosomatic.
Yeah.
And me just thinking,
okay,
this is what fixes me getting dropped or
whatever.
But I did think towards the end,
if I got dropped three times inspiring
before the fight with [inaudible] and
that was in one day and I was like,
okay,
this is,
yeah,
we'll know.
They pulled me out.
If you have to stop now,
you think after the first,
well,
I don't think everybody was,
I mean it's a big sparring room.
I don't think people,
yeah,
I don't think people are paying that
much attention.
I mean,
there's a lot going on then when you get
dropped,
was it a flash knockdown or did you feel
your legs go flash knockdown?
I don't think I've ever been completely
unconscious.
Um,
I yawned limp and then gotten back up.
Yeah.
And it's the same thing.
You,
you
don't recognize your weakness,
right?
You don't recognize that your brain
could have problems,
you don't reckon,
you know?
Right.
As long as you're walking and moving,
you have to keep going for.
Right.
And I think that that mentality,
I don't want to,
um,
I don't want to disrespect that
mentality because I think that's also
the mentality that makes champions.
But if you never became a champion and
you went through that,
you kind of wonder,
I didn't make great choices with my life
right now.
Right,
right,
right.
No,
I think what you're saying rings true to
pretty much anybody that follows a
sport.
Like we really admire those Diego
Sanchez warriors.
You know,
Diego Sanchez fight.
And I'm watching,
you know,
I wouldn't want my kid to fight the way
he fights.
Right.
You know,
diego fights like a,
like a God damn human wolverine.
You know,
he just,
he's just a beast.
Just charge forward.
You know?
I mean,
and he's been stopped and he's lost.
But
okay.
It's just the,
the ferocity and which he approaches
fighting.
It's just,
it's heart and will,
and just determination.
And it's all together in this,
this indomitable spirit package.
You know what I mean?
It's a very,
I mean,
diego might not be a world champion and
you might not ever win a world title,
but the amount of fans that guy has won
just by,
because when he's so entertaining,
like if what you're trying to see when
you're watching two people fight is one
person try to figure out a way to
triumph over the obstacle in front of
them.
That is the person over the,
the body that wants to stop over the
lungs that are burning over the legs
that are giving out.
Okay.
Do you think that rings true now in
entertainment,
in sports?
Do you think that the uh,
the UFC or Belgium or whatever show is
on,
do you think that that's still what
people are looking for
sometimes.
Sometimes.
I mean,
I don't always look for it.
Like I got criticized because people
said that the Tyron Woodley Stephen
Wonderboy Thompson fight wasn't a good
fight.
And I'm like,
while that fight was going on,
I was on the edge of my seat because at
any moment it could have gotten amazing
at any moment.
Dan doing well before their techniques
almost.
I mean not consciously doing mad,
but they,
you know,
they're,
they're adjusting to each other and
second of the fight.
Yeah.
And um,
I thought it,
I thought it was fascinating,
but that wonderboy was playing this very
conservative stay on the outside thing
and Tyron Woodley in order to close the
distance.
He had a risk getting hit and he got hit
a few times.
I mean it was a fascinating fight to me,
but people don't want chess matches.
They want the last minute of the last
round when Tyron connected and Wonderboy
was wobbling and looked like he was
going out,
that's what they want.
They want slobber knocker rocky.
Especially people that don't train,
they just just watch the sport and they
just think,
you know,
oh,
I want to see somebody get their ass
kicked.
You know,
they don't care that someone is using
amazing foot work or that someone has a
completely different style than what
people are used to wonder why,
what that sideways sport sport karate
stance so difficult to decipher when
he's also so good at timing.
It is his sliding in.
And out movement is so good and his
ground is very good too.
And he just,
he doesn't have to go there that often.
Yeah.
Yes.
I just,
I,
I'm a fan of the whole thing.
I like all of it.
I like wars.
I liked tactical matches.
I like a guy like mighty mouse who just
barely ever gets hit.
Yeah.
And I like someone like Diego that comes
out biting down on his mouthpiece and
you,
you know,
it could be covered in blood and he just
fights harder.
Diego Sanchez,
one more third rounds when he got his
ass kicked.
The first two,
like anybody,
the Gilbert Melendez fight,
you know that Jake Ellenberger,
you know the last minute of the fight
he's on,
Jake ellenberger is back,
punched him in the head.
It's crazy.
He's just so ferocious at the Martin
Marvin Kamin.
Same thing.
Martin Kampmann fight.
Martin Kampmann had him like his face
was hanging off,
it was hanging off and he's still
chasing them down to third round.
Might just nobody more ferocious than
that.
Yeah.
Then,
but you know,
and it's the times like that,
like how can you not admire that?
How can you not want to see that or find
something in yourself?
It's like that the will not give up.
That if you're at the brink of,
I mean not necessarily death because
it's just an enactment right of that.
Right.
Let's be real though and we don't want
to,
we were kind of being nice about it,
but it is kind of at the brink of death.
I mean Robbie Mcdonnell,
Robbie lawler and Rory Macdonald,
that was to me the brink of death.
I mean you're,
you're getting really close.
Those guys were fucking going to war and
when Rorys knows caved in and blood's
pouring out of his face and he just
collapses and he couldn't take it
anymore.
I mean,
how far away from death is that?
It's an a couple blocks.
This is the same neighbor.
You could see death from there,
that's for sure.
But does that,
when you're watching it or when you're
analyzing a,
do you feel,
does that feel differently than when you
first started?
I guess watching it,
analyzing when you see these moments now
feels bad.
One,
it,
it does bother me when I know them too.
Well,
you know when I know them too well and
a,
I see them getting,
when I see a fight like,
um,
like Rory Macdonald,
Robbie Lawler,
why no?
Okay.
Whoever wins this fight.
Neither one of those guys going to be
the same again.
They gave a part of who they were in
that fight and you know,
Don fries said that once about his fight
with uh,
Ken shamrock.
He said,
whoever won that fight,
it doesn't matter because we both lost
something.
We both lost who,
whoever we were when we went in there,
we weren't at the same guy when we left.
[inaudible] you know that we left
something.
He goes,
I don't know if Ken's going to admit it,
but I'll tell you,
I lost something in there.
I'm not the same person anymore.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny.
It's,
it's so much,
I guess I'm,
I'm working on so many writing projects
right now and so many things that I'm
trying to analyze mma from such a
different perspective now,
but if you think about it,
what they've sacrificed to that canvas,
like what they've given,
like all of these fighters,
all of these grades and all of these not
greats who've still given that part of
themselves to that canvas.
And You wonder,
uh,
what's the payback exactly.
What,
what do you get from that Tori?
Yeah.
What are those moments,
those moments in the,
and also this understanding that you are
the type of person that can persevere.
I mean,
we've,
we've settled the world basically,
you know,
we've been all over the world.
We know,
we know the world,
we know space.
We're getting out there,
we're figuring those things out.
But these are the,
almost the worlds and the spaces and the
glories let that fight for glory in
these strange heterotopic spaces that we
create for ourselves.
So that what's a heterotopic space?
It's like a,
uh,
it's a,
it's a full cult thing.
It's,
um,
I guess,
well this is like,
I was like,
I was just gonna actually ask you with
podcasting and stuff like that,
it's a space that's other sort of,
that you create an environment that's
other than the norm sort of in a way.
It's kind of hard for me,
it's like non hegemonic.
Um,
but it's um,
for unusual outside the box space.
Yeah.
Strange environment.
It's kind of a,
it's kind of a utopia,
but it's a,
it's a controlled utopia.
It's a Heterotopia like it,
it kind of molds those two ideas.
Okay.
And like I,
and like I was going to ask you to kind
of about podcasting,
stuff like that,
cause you kind of create one when your
voice goes out over the air and when
you're doing these things,
you're entering into people's heads.
You yourself in a way or your,
your voices.
And it's creating this space that's
other where they're connected with you.
Right.
And,
um,
it's just an other space and it's,
and,
and I think that fighting,
and I think the cage is,
is that as well.
I think it's this,
um,
it's this new avenue,
it's this new area.
And that's where I,
I feel so troubled when it comes to the
commercialization of it all because I
wonder if people are still fighting for
Gloria and stuff,
but are they or are they fighting for
the pretty pictures?
I don't know.
Like,
and I can't ask people.
I don't know exactly like I,
I really want the answers to that.
I want to know why people still fight.
I know I did it.
I think everybody has their own
different reasons and sometimes those
reasons don't serve you well.
Like when Ronda Rousey came back and
when she fought Amanda Nunez and all the
lead up was all about Ronda Rousey.
Yeah.
And it was also about her getting back
to being the best in the world.
And I was,
I was watching all that and it was like,
I'm going to be world champion because
fighting is the most important thing.
And I was watching,
I was like,
wow,
this all on paper.
You mean I'm keeping my mind open.
Um,
uh,
I'm excited to see that she's in great
shape.
She's coming back fully motivated,
not excited that she hasn't made any
changes to our camp,
but,
well,
let's see what happens.
She's got amazing judo and she was a
world beater for a real reason,
but I'm,
all the red flags are there,
although wrong.
Yes.
Right.
Nothing about the actual world champion
who exactly who.
Yeah,
and it's like an eye.
I freaking Adore Ronda Rousey and it
means my teammate,
like holly is the one who night,
like how did you thrown to her?
But I,
I adore Rhonda and what she's done and
the things that she's done in that
mentality.
That's a Diego Sanchez mentality.
Not In the way that cheese she
got used to a very specific thing
happening when she fought was her
dominating.
And when that didn't happen in that one
fight,
look,
she tried her best against holly,
but holly fought the perfect fight and
fight.
Ronda fought the wrong fight.
Right.
Absolutely wrong.
The wrong way to fight holly charge at
her.
Yeah.
With the,
yeah.
Yeah.
I and holly was so ready for that fight.
She was,
she was ready for that fight for years.
Like,
I can
see that I could just see in her knee.
She fought perfect.
Yeah.
I mean it was literally a flawless
performance by all.
Yeah.
So she loses that fight.
She gets devastated and chalks it off to
lack of training.
Chalks it off to distractions.
So this time she's going to do no media.
She's going to do no interviews,
no nothing.
Just go in there and just be bulldog.
Dot.
But when you,
you see like the discussions about this
fight and you see,
uh,
people,
you know that we're there,
we're behind the scenes.
They were all convinced that she was
going to steam roll.
Amanda Nunez.
There was so many people back there.
I was like,
you guys are out of your fucking mind.
I was saying before the holly fight,
then Amanda was probably the most
dangerous fight for because a man is
really fucking good on the ground and
her standup is vicious.
Like she got brutal knockout power and
she's a long,
like she throws,
he's long ass punches and she catches
you on the end of these punches.
I'm like,
that's up nightmare for Rhonda because
Rhonda likes to stand up and bra to
close the distance.
And the name of your close the diseases
with Amanda Nunez is no picnic.
No.
And you know,
Amanda's got actually a very good clench
in a very,
a very good awareness of where her body
goes and hurt her center of gravity
seems to be she's,
you're right.
She's so long.
It seems to be a little bit lower than,
you know,
I think it would be very hard to launch
her on her head,
although Zingano did very well with the
yeah,
belly to belly.
Suplex that's what that was.
Right.
I got to remember that
one other woman who's fucking ferocious
as hell.
Cats in Ghana.
So much intensity.
I remember,
you know,
I first met her in Colorado.
We were on the same fight show.
It was when I filmed tap out and I tried
to go say hi to her because Oh,
another female fighter,
you know,
we weren't fighting each other and she
just totally,
and I was like,
oh,
what a bitch.
Like,
and then I got to know her better and
she just like,
she is an amazing person.
She is.
She had a fight coming up.
She didn't wanna talk to anybody.
She didn't want to have,
you know who I was,
you know,
I didn't know who she was and we weren't
gonna talk.
And then,
yeah.
And then I just got to absolutely adore
her.
But you know,
back to Rhonda and all of that,
I,
I feel like it's interesting,
the Diego Sanchez,
like kind of the mentality that the bite
down in the third round,
I think you have something there where
you pushed when it's against you.
Yeah.
And I wonder that something that,
that knockout interrupted her or you
know,
when holly got her an interrupted her,
her forward progression and then going
back,
pulling back away from the media and
stuff,
I almost wonder if that in itself was
kind of a denial of that interruption
and maybe uh,
trying to create a space for herself.
I don't know.
I'm so obsessed with this idea of
creating our own spaces and what we're
doing in our own lives because
everybody's so different than
individual.
Yeah.
And,
and what she was trying to,
I guess,
plot out the way to this fight and to
waive this victory against Amanda Nunez
and not being distracted and not doing
press and stuff like that.
And I almost think if she'd had done the
press,
and this is just a theory,
I don't,
I don't know her that well.
I think she's a lovely person.
But if she had done the of sheet,
exposed herself to all of that,
again,
if she wouldn't have had more of a
triumphant attitude because she would
have known.
When you know what it's like to lose and
you know that you can still get up the
next day and be okay and,
and face the people who you said a
million things to a million confident
thanks to and and you're wrong or you
were wrong for a night and understand
that you can actually still get them to
see your side.
I don't know if that makes any sense.
It does.
I see what you're saying.
I see where you're going with it.
I don't know.
You know,
I think there's a bunch of problems
technically with how she's preparing in
all.
I think her work with Edmond made her
look really good on the mets,
but there's a big difference between
looking good on the mats and having a
bunch of different options tactically
when you're in a fight.
And I think a lot of that comes with
just long,
long sessions in the gym,
a lot of experience and years and years
of sparring.
And fighting,
but she was just go forward,
go forward to tackle forward attack and
when she started getting hit,
she didn't have any answers.
She was like throwing up this sort of
push away front kick and moving away
against Amanda and she was kind of done
from like the first couple of punches
landed and I think that if you look at
real seasoned strikers,
you know like like a good example would
be,
oh boy,
there's a lot of good examples,
but you want to get in j check and a her
last fight against Carolina Kibawe
Kovich okay.
That that is two very seasoned strikers.
There was a lot of like a lot of faints.
There was a lot of different angles.
There's a lot of different approaches.
He was try one way that doesn't work.
Let's go over here.
That doesn't work.
Let's go over here now I've got
something.
Let's try that again.
Went to the well too many times.
Try back to this again.
There was,
there was,
it was a communication.
It was like there's a conversation going
on.
What you're seeing a lot of fighters is
they're shouting out one or two words
but they're not articulate.
Meaning their approach is very,
if you see someone and they just keep
going to the big right hand over the
top,
big right hand over the top,
it's like you're just banking on this
one thing and someone is going to be
able to figure out that approach and it
might not be the person that's right in
front of you,
but someone who's really good is going
to find their way through that and
they're going to be able to talk circles
around you.
Like I,
I talk all the time about when I watch
finding,
I tried to break it down objectively.
I'm saying what it mirrors in a lot of
ways is communication and that really
truly articulate.
People that have a long list,
the long history of using a deep
vocabulary are way better off with a
nuanced conversation than someone who is
just,
they might be able to say,
get off my lawn.
You know,
they might be able to yell out one
phrase,
but how can they adapt to someone who's
passive?
How can they adapt to someone who tricks
them?
How can they adapt to someone who paints
them into a corner and like,
can you figure your way out of a trap?
Do you understand a trap?
And when you see it in fighting,
you see people getting set up and you
see things happening.
Like Anderson,
like Anderson Silva was a master at
setting people up in a master of that.
Like figuring out the language of what
you do.
What do you do?
Like what's your thing?
Like what you could see him when he was
moving with guys,
he would stand south Paul,
he would switch up,
he moved around,
he would give you a little of this and
he just tried to Jay.
And then eventually he'd figure out your
rhythm and then start dropping shit on
you.
And when he did,
it was masterful to watch.
Cause here's a guy that had figured out
whatever rhythm Yuron he'd figured out
the symphony of your movements.
Beautiful.
I think it's beautiful and I think that
describing that,
uh,
as a conversation with another person,
it's perfect.
It is a dialogue between two people.
Yeah,
it's a dialogue of,
of physicality and strength and stuff
like that.
But it's it,
there's a conversation happening there
in the cage.
And I think when we go back to maybe the
aspects of,
I actually think that Ronda Rousey's
training might have been a little bit to
boxing oriented.
Not that she didn't throw kicks,
not that she didn't use her judo,
but she didn't prepare for chaos.
And I don't know,
the boxers always prepare for chaos
because it's such a,
a layered this step,
you move your,
your foot this way,
you move your foot this way,
you move your head this way,
you respond this way.
You know it's,
it's so beautiful.
But when you see boxers like,
like Tyson who could throw that double
right,
you know,
the,
the hook to the body and then the upper
cut and stuff like that.
He could prepare for the chaos cause he
couldn't bring chaos.
And I think that in her early fights
sheet there was chaos there because she
wasn't as sure of herself.
It was,
wow,
I got to get what I need to get and that
unsettled fighters.
But then when she got more comfortable
with hitting the Mitts,
when she got more comfortable with them
moving forward and,
and having everything laid out for her
perfectly,
you're going to do this,
you're going to start this person,
this is going to happen.
Now I'm making a lot of assumptions
here.
I never trained with.
Right.
I never sparred with her.
I,
I see what I've been presented by UFC
media and commercials and I do as well
as well as people that I know the train
were there.
Didn't like the environment.
Yeah.
Dot.
That it was just a little bit to an
unrealistic and that's I think what
maybe the conversation between old
school emma man,
what's going on in mma right now with
commercialization and it's worldwide.
And I,
on one hand,
I'm so happy for the fighters that
they're getting paid more that,
that the opportunities are there,
that,
you know,
they don't have to worry about crappy
sponsors,
although I'm not a huge reebok fan,
but whatever,
it's not my business like,
but,
um,
the,
they don't prepare for chaos anymore as
much.
And Chaos was what we thrived on back in
the day.
Right?
We didn't know who we were going to
fight.
I fought three pill and one in three
people in one night.
One time I lost a fight and then the
next day I took a kickboxing fight cause
I was so mad I lost an MMA fight.
Like there was no regulation and I could
have gotten seriously injured.
Right.
But at the same time it was that chaos
that was so beautiful.
Like finding where you are in the chaos
and,
and finding your own patterns in that
and preparing for it.
And that's,
I don't know,
that's the old school mma that I miss a
little bit.
While there's definitely something
interesting and fascinating about that
chaos,
but there's also,
when you're talking about a professional
and when you're talking about someone
who's a world champion in particular,
there's real value in preparation for an
individual opponent,
right?
And you switch up at opponent last men
and or something happens like when conor
mcgregor last minute wasn't facing
Hofeld dose on Joe Saul's son who was
facing Nate Diaz on 11 days notice.
I mean that,
that kind of chaos is,
is completely different animal.
I,
I totally agree with you and you know,
I might be contradicting myself here,
but I don't care.
Because also when Jon Jones were
ejected,
the,
the fight,
the initial,
like when jail was supposed to step in
for him and he said,
no,
that's not what my team,
you know,
once and he got so much shit for that
and the whole event got cancelled at the
same time.
It's just like,
that's a pretty smart professional move
to make.
It is and it isn't,
you know,
I think John also didn't want to risk
reward chill sign and for all that shit.
But my thought is John Jones smokes jail
sign and if you wake them up at five
o'clock in the morning after he's been
out drinking,
yeah.
I just,
I just don't think they're in the same
stratosphere.
No,
I don't think so either.
Um,
but I do think that that,
although it was a move that affected a
lot of people negatively who were
supposed to be on that card and it
affected the company negatively,
it was a very big power move and it was
also a move towards saying,
hey,
I'm,
I'm more professional than this.
You can't do that to me.
Yeah,
I agree.
But if I was in John's corner opposite,
listen to me,
dude,
you're the motherfuckers.
All motherfuckers go out there and smash
that dude.
The person who was with the people in
his corner,
I would say they're going to do things
the way they see best for him.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
But that's not the rumble Johnson.
No,
but that's also the way,
that's also the ways,
if you're not prepared specifically,
like I,
again,
I'm going back to what I was saying
about the chaos,
but you have to train for chaos and you
do have to be prepared specifically for
opponents.
You're very right in that.
You have to know what somebody is going
to do.
That's how holly was so successful about
Rhonda.
She knew every move that was going to
come her way.
Right.
And I think that when you switch things
up on such a level where it was that big
of a fight,
somebody he'd been preparing for a
Henderson,
it was Henderson,
right?
Am I,
John was spinning Henderson and one 57
I,
there were a lot of fights fighting.
Who thought it was who had to pull out a
lot of fights.
I don't know.
I just,
I know jail came in and it was,
it was a quest guy,
right?
He's supposed to be Dan Henderson.
Really thought so.
It was a quest guy.
Did Dan Henderson and Jones ever fight?
No,
I'm,
I'm pretty sure it was hundred.
I could be completely mistaken,
but yeah,
Dan Henderson did fight Daniel cormier.
Remember that fight and Daniel just
sorta ragdoll I'm all over the place.
I don't know.
I don't remember who the hell John was
supposed to fight.
It just seemed as though those are the
moments where a legacy can be very
shaken.
Now John's done his own work of shaking
up his own legacy.
John just needs someone to talk to.
I think that we all make poor choices
and some people's poor choices are a
little bit bigger than other people's
four choices.
Well and is also wild.
Motherfuckers do wild motherfucker shit
like you want some do two opens up with
Shogun,
with a flying knee when he's 22 years
old and catch a Shogun on the chin.
That's Jon Jones.
And that,
that whole wild man thing is the reason
why he's so God damn good in the first
place because he has amazing confidence.
What makes John's special is like the
Gustafson fight,
a fight that he admittedly was in shitty
shape for.
It really wasn't training,
was partying way too much,
wasn't really paying attention,
didn't think Gustafson can beat him and
got dragged deep into the fifth round.
Still wound up winning.
He didn't fold up.
He fought.
I mean,
he wound up winning the fifth round.
He winded up taking it to him.
He pulled that fight out and he made it.
Uh,
I mean,
look,
us up sends a bad motherfucker.
It's not like Gustafson was a pushover,
but John Jones made that fight way
harder than it was.
But I'm not being conditioned,
not being in shape and still got it it
out in one.
Yeah,
he had that.
I think that that part of him that I
hope he returns to that is all about
that.
I don't know those Diego Sanchez
moments,
like when you just,
it,
it becomes your spirit that's fighting.
They're not just your body.
That's funny.
But something else has to take over and
take the reins
one,
two or popped his arm and beat the veto
or had his arms.
So hyper extended.
I thought he was going to tab,
I was like,
holy.
I was hoping I just,
do you want to see his arm break?
You know what I mean?
It was fucking nasty.
And which is tow is half torn off in
that other,
we didn't know about that.
He just didn't feel it.
Like that's another level.
Yeah.
He didn't know about that until he was
doing the post fight interview and
looked down and saw his toe and he was
like,
Holy Shit.
And then we got him a stool and he sat
down on the stool and he was kind of in
shock.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I always called him my little brother at
the gym,
but I always,
yeah,
it's been,
he's not my look,
I guess.
I haven't been at the gym in a long
time.
So
John is almost too talented for his own
good and surrounded by the wrong kind of
people.
I think that he does that.
Yeah.
I think that he,
there's something about him that self
sabotages.
Yeah,
it's easy.
It's easy to self sabotage,
you know,
it's like the pressure of being a Jon
Jones.
What do you think about the amount of
money that guy missed out on?
You know,
and then he's,
he's coming back in July and he'll most
likely be fighting the winter of Daniel
Cormier.
I Rung Rumble Johnson,
which is in a couple of months.
If they could do that in time.
Cause you've,
you've got to go may,
June,
July,
maybe.
I mean it really depends on how this
fight goes,
but he still has a chance to pull it off
and still has a chance to be the
greatest of all time.
But he's fucked up pretty hard.
I liked John Though.
I just think John's around the wrong
fucking people.
He's a good dude.
I just think that,
um,
yeah,
I,
I think that we all wake up at some
point and I just think his wakeup hasn't
happened yet.
Like even with maybe with the
suspensions and the stuff that he's
saying,
but I think that he also tried very hard
to brand himself a certain way that
again,
authenticity and authentic and
authenticity.
You know,
like I think that I'm sure that I,
I'm not a religious person,
so I don't really know how to say if
somebody is being Super Christian or not
being Super Christian and being whatever
that they,
they identify with.
Like I,
it's not my,
that's not my knowledge sphere,
but I will say that it didn't seem the
things that he was saying didn't jive
with how he was and it came out and
people hated him for it.
They did get mad at that because he was
trying to present this goody two shoes
image and meanwhile he's a wild man.
Yeah.
And,
yeah,
you know,
the wild man is a respected figure in
and that made me respect it.
But it's a,
it's a vulnerable figure in society.
Like Donald Cowboy cerrone is a perfect
example.
Yeah.
Hundred percent on his sleeve.
Wow.
Yeah.
I love him.
He's,
yeah,
and a good dude.
But yeah,
wild man.
He has to have those rushes.
He has to have that,
that danger coming out him,
uh,
he lives for it genuinely lives for it
and without it,
he doesn't feel as,
as tuned in and doesn't feel as alive.
It's crazy fucking sport.
Julie.
Kedsey crazy.
I want to know you.
I want to know about you.
Who were you when you first started all
this?
Who Was it?
Yeah.
Who were you and are you the same person
now?
Who are you like?
Well who was Joe Rogan?
Well,
it's just like,
it's something I'm,
I'm,
I'm thinking about these heterotopic
spaces and thinking about authenticity.
I'm like,
here's a person.
I was actually just going to email you
these questions.
I was like,
oh well if I come in here I can plug
invicta and that would be great.
Cause I love plugging in victim,
but I'm also,
I just,
I,
I've never really sat down and talked to
you and I guess who were you when this
started and who are you now?
Like are you the same person?
Yeah,
well I'm not the same person I was six
months ago.
I mean that's just,
yeah,
I would imagine if you're constantly
thinking about things and constantly
growing and trying to reevaluate
constantly.
Uh,
yeah,
I was younger,
I was just a few years removed from
martial arts competition and kickboxing
and was doing some acting and stuff.
Did you train stand up?
Did you sorta had to take a few acting
classes when I got a development deal,
but it was because I already had a
television show and so they said,
hey,
you should learn how to act.
It was really that.
It wasn't then.
It was something that I trained for.
No,
I,
um,
I was doing standup and I got a
development deal,
do a sitcom.
And so then all of a sudden I found
myself out here and,
uh,
you know,
I was like,
when I moved out here,
I was like 25,
six,
something like that.
And I was just trying to figure out what
I'm doing,
like my,
my acting like this is,
this whole thing is weird,
you know.
And then a couple of years later,
I guess it was 97,
I was training at Carlson Gracie's place
and [inaudible] was 19.
And,
uh,
he had just beaten John Hassle over in
Hawaii.
I was a white belt over there and,
um,
Mario Sperry train there and Carlos by
Hereto and I'm Maria Lowe Bustamonte so
watch those guys.
Train was amazing.
And this was back when no one knew any
of those guys where,
you know,
it was,
it was really,
really interesting.
It was a really interesting to be a part
of that,
uh,
original Carlson Gracie,
Jim and watch those guys work out
together and watch everything.
And so when,
um,
the UFC needed a post-fight interviewer,
they had a,
they just had con one of the guys who
was one of the producers,
Campbell Mclaren was friends with my
manager and they just casually mentioned
it and they brought it up to me and then
we had a conference call and I was like,
Oh fuck,
I'll do that.
Like,
what do you want me to do?
And so the next thing you knew,
I was flying out to Dothan,
Alabama on those little propeller
planes.
I was interviewing Mark Coleman.
I was like,
this is crazy.
Watching vidor Belfort's debut.
Um,
you know,
it was a fascinating time and to catch
mma sort of in,
it's transitioned from being the
spectacle that it once was just four
years prior to becoming a sport.
Like Vitara entered the octagon.
He had gloves on.
You know,
Vito used to fight with shoes on
sometimes and got you were,
you were still out of glad grab clothes
back then because I remember this guy,
uh,
had,
I forget who a volleyed Ishmael fought,
but uh,
he literally was grabbing his underwear
and his pants and giving them this like
intense wedgie while they were fighting.
Like his cop was snapping and he was
totally legal.
Yeah,
yeah.
You didn't have to have gloves the way
classes were,
you know,
it was only two weight classes.
I think back then it was real weird.
It was real,
it was weird to be there and you know,
it was interesting and I did it for a
couple of years and then it just doesn't
seem like it was going anywhere.
It was,
mma was stagnant.
It was removed from cable.
You could only get it if you had direct
TV.
So I did it for two years and then I
quit and um,
went back to doing other stuff and just
sit calm.
I was on and stuff.
And then the UFC was purchased by
[inaudible] and then I became friends
with Dana and went to a few shows and
then next thing you know he asked me to
do commentary.
It was one of those weird things where I
have zero desire to do it.
I just was talking to him,
I go,
hey man,
do you know about this guy?
He's fighting over in Japan.
Do you know about this guy,
this Russian dude,
do you know about this guy?
And he'd be like,
no,
who's,
who are these people you write things
down and shit.
Cause I was just balls deep in k one and
cried and all that.
I was just,
I was always a huge,
huge fan.
And I had my friend Brian from Canada
would send me vhs tapes of all these
Japanese shows.
So I would just,
I was just a massive fan.
The Hook can shoot days.
I watched all the hook and shoots all
Jeff Osborne shows and uh,
you know,
and then somewhere around,
I guess it was 2002 when I was on fear
factor,
they asked me to do commentary.
And then I've been doing it ever since.
So that's it.
That's it.
Yeah,
that's it.
And now,
like do you ever look at your old stuff?
Do you ever consider like your mind
space then?
You mean like the old commentary stuff
or just even think about it.
Do my best every time I do it,
but honestly what my contribution is is
so it's,
it's,
I want to say it's insignificant,
but it's not very important because what
it is is just me trying to do the best I
can describe what I see in front of me
to make it as entertaining,
as make it as entertaining as I can,
but also honor what's happening.
You're a conduit.
You're the person.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're,
you're where the flow of information has
to come through for the average viewer.
Yeah.
No,
I really admire that about you.
I'm not trying to suck up,
but your enthusiasm is something I
really tried to model myself after.
Like I,
I,
I think that we have,
like I'm nowhere near the level of
commentator that you are,
but when I hear you get excited about
stuff,
I'm really happy to hear that because it
makes me think,
okay,
as somebody who's communicating what's
happening in this sphere that so many
people know about,
but so many people don't really
understand like what's going on if
somebody is clenched up or they're
grabbing a bicep here and why that's
important,
why the way this fight or shifting their
hips is so important.
You know?
And,
and it's,
it's cool to see that kind of enthusiasm
so that I
guess other people can get excited about
something without even knowing they're
getting excited.
Like they're there.
The blood pressure comes up a little bit
when they're watching and that's neat.
It's neat to see that cause it seems
genuine.
All a hundred percent genuine.
This is the only sport that I really
follow.
I mean,
I don't really even understand football.
I don't know what's going on.
Like when the whistle blows or what
happened.
I don't know what happened.
And you know,
people make fun of me all the time for
that,
but I'm like,
it's not interesting to me when I'd
kickboxing,
boxing,
wrestling,
Jiu Jitsu and mma,
watching all that takes up plenty of
time.
I don't have time for anything else.
I just don't.
And the consequences just aren't the
same.
I mean,
when,
when I watch a kickboxing match or watch
an MMA fight,
the consequences are so extreme that I'm
engaged,
I'm captivated.
And with mma,
you know,
when I'm watching it and I'm there live
and I'm,
I'm cage side and I'm,
I'm watching all this stuff go down and
I'm not just watching,
but I'm also analyzing it.
So I'm trying to decipher patterns and
I'm trying,
I'm data chunking and trying to figure
out what,
what could possibly happen,
what am I seeing in my projecting this
or am I actually seeing this?
And just trying to be like as empty
about it as I can,
but also be so enthusiastic about it.
And then it's like,
there's moments like,
uh,
when Darren Elkins beat [inaudible],
it's just so hard for me not to cry
inside the octagon.
It was so hard.
Oh,
I believe it.
Yeah,
but I was interviewing that do like,
I'll,
I'll start welling up right now.
When I was interviewing him after that
fight,
I was like,
that guy just emptied out.
You mean emptied out his whole soul.
I mean,
he took up fucking beating for two and a
half rounds and didn't give up an inch.
There was nothing,
there was no quit in him.
None.
Zero.
And then filing the third round,
he catches that guy and there's this
fucking roar that he did after that
fight was stopped where he throws his
arm back and he's moving around the cage
and screaming.
He's covered in blood like right there.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's one of the purest human moments
you can ever see it,
isn't it?
Like,
like I,
yeah,
you have to wipe tears off my hours.
Right.
No,
I totally understand that.
Like it's amazing.
It's amazing to,
I guess to see your passion for that and
to see you are able to witness that and
you're still able to translate that kind
of passionate people.
Well if it stops being that to me,
I'm going to stop doing it.
But that was just last fight.
I mean it doesn't,
it just did.
Not only is it not stopped,
there's no,
like when the fights are going on,
there's no waning whatsoever in my
enthusiasm.
It's not.
It hasn't,
it hasn't dissipated and people think
like,
oh,
he's kind of half and now because he
doesn't do all the events like that.
And that can be further from the truth.
I just don't want to travel.
No.
And also you're going to,
you're going to wear yourself down to a
certain point where it's just like
you're going to be too sick to actually
be able to experience what you need to
experience for the viewer to feel what's
going on.
That's awesome.
I have too many interests.
I do too.
I like to do too many things.
I just,
I'm trying to do,
I'm trying to live five lives,
you know?
I mean if you have the opportunity to,
why not does it does wear you thin a
little bit.
Did you,
did you have that kind of passionate
connection with comedy?
Like when,
when you're doing standup and when
you're,
when you're in that kind of engagement,
do you feel that flow where you're just
almost to the point of emotion and you
want to cry?
No,
not like that.
That's different because it's a life or
death.
Like Dud Darren Elkins fight was life or
It was a,
it's a different thing.
It's not,
it's like comedy is fun.
It's like joyful.
It's silly.
It's important in that I know that
people come out to see me and they pay
money and I want to do my best.
It's important that I'm trying to
constantly improve.
What I do is I dump all our material out
every two years.
So I ride a special,
I perform it,
I get it tight and then I record it.
I put it on whatever,
on Netflix or whatever,
and then I'm done.
And then,
um,
and then I have to write a whole new
one.
And that process is a long and painful
process.
Like I did my netflix special in
November.
It came out in November,
so it's been December,
January,
February,
March.
We're four months in now.
So it's like on like fon legs.
It's like,
it's just sort of like trotting along
now.
It's not really like a cult,
you know,
it's not really like fully formed yet,
but it will get fully formed.
And then once it gets hardened and once
I know that it's ready to rock,
like I could smash for an hour,
then I chuck it out.
And so there's a lot of intensity in
that regard.
But it's a different kind of intensity.
Like the,
the kind of,
it's a fun intensity.
There's a,
there's a motion.
It's like there's,
you know,
jokes that don't go well and it's
painful and I don't enjoy that.
But I also know that that's where the
growth comes from.
Like those shitty sets or with like some
of my biggest leaps have come from af
posts sets where it wasn't good.
And then I was sort of reengage and
reconnect and it got more fired up.
And as soon as that stops being
important to me,
I'll stop doing that too.
But it doesn't have the same feeling
that fighting has fighting is,
has,
is unique,
unique moment.
This unique thing to it.
Like that Darren Elkins fight where it's
like,
man,
there's not a whole lot of things like
that in the world that you can witness.
Where did that fucking intense and that
I have the honor to try to do service
to,
to try to,
I would say fighting is one of the few
arts or sports or however you wanna
phrase it.
Experiences in the world where the
stakes are immediately,
hi there laid out there.
The stakes are high.
You win or lose isn't just win or lose
to a fighter and it's not win or lose to
a fan.
Although you can step back and say that
or you can say,
well,
I'm just watching this for energy,
but you get invested.
It gets so invested in it.
I think that's,
I was kind of a lousy matchmaker in that
sense that I cared about the girls too
much.
I really did and I was just like,
I didn't want anybody to lose ever and
it's was just like,
you know,
I was [inaudible] it was terrible.
With the math
and the Oregon.
I'm just,
I'm a very,
very hyperactive,
like not when I'm in the zone,
I can pay attention really well,
but when I'm not,
it's I'm,
my mind is everywhere and I can't really
focus and I wasn't,
I wasn't great in that respect.
Um,
but man,
when you see something come together
though,
when you see the fight actually happen
and it does matter who wins or who
loses.
But it also doesn't,
what matters is just watching that
physical engagement and these people
perform at their not performing,
but they are performing.
Yes.
It's,
I don't know,
it's a cat is an art.
You know,
like when Meryl Streep was saying that,
yeah,
my may is not the arts.
Well listen,
it's not painting,
but guess what?
It's art.
Yeah.
It's on a damn canvas.
Like,
I mean really it is like,
it is,
I mean it's,
it's a contained,
these actions are being performed.
It's hard.
It just,
it may not be what
we identify as art,
but neither is the person in the modern
art with the TV or whatever you were
talking about earlier.
Like,
wow,
you see a fight like me should tape
versus Holly Holm.
When Misha take takes holly home down in
the fifth round locks that choke in and
holly doesn't even tab,
she's throwing punches in the air as she
goes on conscious and you know,
there's people on the outside,
they would look at that and go,
oh,
that's just barbaric and it's just
violent.
But you see Misha tate getting that belt
strapped around her waist and her
reaction,
oh my gosh.
They the her whole life,
she was the strike force team.
Rosie came,
yeah.
You bantamweight champion other wow.
Yeah,
she was climbed.
She summited the highest
mountain that she could summit in that
time.
It was hard.
Yeah.
There was art.
The way I described mma,
my,
my definition is it's high level problem
solving with dire physical consequences
and that's really what it is.
But it's also done in an like,
especially when you watch Anderson fight
in his prime.
It was beautiful.
It was beautiful to watch.
Like there was a statics involved that
were undeniably artistic.
It was just,
there's a lesson going on
fight and I can't recall it right now
where he mimicked all of these different
styles and like he did it a cup of water
move and then he did this and he was at
like all in one fight.
Like he was monkeying around.
I should,
I don't mean that in,
I guess that sounds racist and I don't
mean that.
I mean,
yeah,
in the playful sentences or whatever.
Ridiculous.
Where are we live in?
I can't say monkey and around if it's a
black guy.
Well I,
I mean I want to respect if something
that I say offend somebody,
I want to respect their angle of
offense.
He didn't mean anything.
I didn't,
but I in the sense to convey in term.
Yeah.
And,
and when,
when he's playing around like that,
I guess when he's,
when he's mimicking other things and
you're just like,
this is a fight and you're able to just
play a completely different game.
Well he was also part of his strategy
g and that's what,
what sort of turned against him and
Chris Weidman fine.
Yeah.
Cause that playing around sort of,
it was
walk your danger,
you know,
like,
I'm sorry I talking over you.
No,
please go ahead.
Oh,
the Nick Diaz did it back then when he
laid down.
I loved that.
That was one of my favorite moments in
any fight and it wasn't even anybody
getting hit Nicolaes down.
He puts his hands together.
I know.
He was like Anderson to Anderson.
He played,
he played,
he played the game and it was like
amazing nicus.
Incredible.
Well next starts talking shit to you.
I think frank shamrock set a pass.
He's like,
you can't believe it's happening.
You know,
I can't believe this guy beating my ass.
And he's talking shit to me.
I mean I remember when he fought Robbie
lawler and he was just constantly
talking shit to him while he was
fighting.
You could see like Robbie was like,
what is going on here?
I give fucks with their heads in
people's heads.
It's the complete,
that's the bench go.
Hey Gosh,
I know,
right?
Oh batch you have.
No,
but it's the complete,
like he's lying down ones.
He's chilling.
How has,
I mean,
come on.
That's one of the funniest moments in
the history of fighting it is those are
the moments when you're just like,
this is somebody who doesn't give a
fuck.
Well he was also trying to get Anderson
to engage in Anderson.
The whole thing with Anderson was
counter striking [inaudible] Patrick
[inaudible] sort of expose that and a
lot of ways,
cause Patrick Otay didn't lead,
he just waited on Anderson and Anderson
was like,
I don't like this.
Yeah,
yeah.
You cause yeah,
counter striker is,
um,
they,
they have their own,
I guess their own methodology with being
able to read what's happening and if
somebody doesn't initiate,
there's a lot of waiting.
Yeah.
And waiting is,
you know,
it makes the fans hate you and it makes
you hate yourself because you get more
frustrating.
You're saying your,
your emotions get more intense.
Right?
Yeah.
It's,
especially when you get to a fight like
wonderboy thompson versus Tyron Woodley
where you see this waiting thing and
it's just going on and on and on and you
know,
five rounds and you're like,
yeah,
it's not
fan friendly.
Right.
But for the fighters,
any wrong move at that point and that
waiting game like that could be death.
Yes.
You know,
loss loss for sure.
For sure.
Um,
what excites you now that you're not
fighting?
Like what?
What excites you about this
or oh,
the sport.
It's the stories.
I'm a sucker for the stories.
The whole reason I went back to school
as I was reading some of those long from
essays Ama may writers were doing.
And I was like,
you know what?
I was doing the matchmaking,
it was doing okay at it.
I was doing the commentary,
but I was like,
I'm just not reaching that thing that I
was reaching when I was fighting.
Something about me is not being
expressed.
So I,
I took a class,
a writing class,
wrote an essay and um,
it got me into school and I was like,
and I mean,
I wa,
I mean it's like one of the best schools
for writing.
I aware.
Where does two things,
well,
wrestling and writing and so you get in
there.
Yeah.
Was,
I was just so,
and I feel alive now.
Like,
I feel like I'm,
I'm back where I'm back to being the
Julie.
I need to be where I'm hungry for
something again.
And it's words and stories.
And I think that MMA is the perfect,
I dunno,
avenue for all of these stories because
you know,
everybody at first in old interviews,
people would just say whatever the fuck
they wanted to say and they do whatever
the fuck they want to do.
And then everybody
got savvy to this,
the media,
right?
And they're just like,
I'm only going to reveal this.
I'm only gonna reveal this.
Right.
And other people played on that and
they're like,
I'm going to give more information,
I'm going to give soundbites.
And so I think that when it comes to
communication and words in mma and what
fighters are giving,
um,
there's a lot about what's not being
said that can really be explored.
And I'd really like to know what that
is.
I want to know what makes a fighter
note,
what makes a fighter decided to fight.
But what makes a fighter decided to wake
up the next day after a fight?
I,
you know,
decide to wake up when,
yeah,
I mean,
it's so emotional.
It's so crazy.
And fighters are such insane people that
after a loss,
I'm surprised actually there aren't more
suicides and stuff like that in this
sport.
And I don't mean to get more,
oh,
super serious.
But people's take it to such a high
level and,
and with the amount of,
of pain that they invest in themselves
and the amount of emotion towards it,
when fighters decide,
I lost this fight and I lost this fight,
but I'm going to get back in,
I'm going to do it again.
Like if they decide they make the
conscious choice to stay,
not necessarily,
I don't know if it's living in the sense
of biologically living or just living in
that space still of wanting to be a
fighter of wanting to do that.
Some people,
oh,
it's all I know.
All I know I've,
all I've ever known is fighting.
So when the fighting is over,
what do you do?
What do they do?
And I was just talking to him favor
about that.
But I think that he's a real good role
model to young fighters cause he's as
enthusiastic as about his post fight
career.
He's like,
Hey,
this is a new chapter of my life and I'm
excited.
I'm excited to do different things now.
I went out with a win,
you know,
and I love the fact that he did that.
He fought in Sacramento in his hometown
and gets a tough guy and Brad Pickett
beats brad and he's like,
I'm going to go out with a win and I'm
onto the next chapter.
Thank you all so much.
And he gets his giant round of applause
and good for him.
Yeah,
he came from a place of,
um,
I guess of,
Oh I think privilege is the wrong word
because he built what he built.
It does not privilege,
but maybe he came from a place of being
able to see a bigger picture.
But then you think about lane,
be the Joe Frazier's of the sport or
anything like that when they stopped
fighting.
What,
you know,
he built a gym,
he did this,
he did that.
But like what,
I don't know,
fighter stories to me are incredible.
The reasons that people fight and the
reasons that commentators commentate,
the reasons that people are still so
emotionally invested in this sport and
what those stories are and what keeps
people going.
I love that.
I think that there's something to the
creation we have built.
I mean the fertittas and Dana built like
the UFC,
but I mean we as fighters,
as a fighter community,
as mma community have built something
incredible and,
and I am interested in why we still want
to occupy this space or what makes
people want to leave it,
but then come back and maybe that's just
my own personal journey because I can't
get out of it.
I can't,
I can't quit mma.
It has been the greatest love of 10 I
mean the life going down to level four.
It's like,
yeah,
you can't mimic the intensity.
You can't,
and I'm finding in words and in,
in communication,
I'm finding something there.
I'm finding that I can,
I can access this.
Again,
it's harder for me because I have to use
my brain work,
but I can't just go in there kicking and
punching.
Like I have to like sit and think about
things.
I have to formulate these questions for
life that I've never even thought about.
But you got to love the questions like
real case side,
you know what I mean?
The questions are what's important,
not even the answers.
It's just finding the right questions to
ask him.
Going through that.
And I've really rediscovered a love for
this sport by stepping away from it.
Um,
every commentary job that I do now,
every time I'm in there for Invicta,
I'm just,
this is amazing.
And,
and finding that enthusiasm and again,
as is,
it's great.
I didn't have that towards the end of my
fight career.
I was in the UFC because that was the
dream.
I had to be in the UFC.
Why does an Invicta,
how ring card boys?
Um,
Shannon thinks that's kind of
disrespectful to boys.
No,
I think that she makes it more of a
spectacle.
So plus these are employees and I think
it's a spectacle for girls too.
I have my own opinions about all of
that,
like the male gaze and mma and stuff
like that.
But the male gaze,
the male gaze.
Yeah.
Well it's just eats,
I mean we are formulated to see things,
I mean ring card girls or tradition that
have come over from boxing and stuff
like that.
And it's never been questioned.
Why,
you know,
it's like,
well,
why do we still have this?
I mean we can put up the ring number
nine a a jumbo tron.
Yeah.
And same time,
I don't want these women to lose their
jobs.
I mean they're,
they're part of the brand and the
promotional aspect of it.
But in the marine corps,
girls for Invicta,
we call them the phoenix girls and
they're actually,
I mean an Natasha Kingsbury's like a
professional runner.
Like,
I mean,
they're serious high level like there,
you know,
she used to be ring card girl for the,
yeah,
she's so great and she's very yoga mind.
He's really cool.
Yeah.
So,
um,
but no,
I think that Shannon doesn't want that.
I guess that spectacle illness,
although I would,
I would argue that the ring girls are
spectacle in in that self,
but I don't know.
I really liked,
I really liked them.
Like the girls that worked for us,
the women who worked for us.
Yeah,
really odd isn't it that there's like
female ring card girls and an all
female?
Like what if we had ring card boys in
the UFC for all the men fights.
Who'd be really weird if guys are
walking around with Speedos,
with high top
box.
If we think about seeing that for the
first time,
can visually picture that right now
because we're not used to it.
Yeah,
it would be weird,
but I mean if it was the norm then I
don't think it would be that weird.
I think and bodybuilder dudes,
you remember King of the cage when they
had that guy who was the king of the
cage who was just gigantic it a
bodybuilder.
Dude wasn't even fighting,
but he was the king of the king of the
cage.
It didn't make any sense.
It was like,
what is happening here?
What is this supposed to represent?
It kind of goes back to branding and
like the weird ways we do that.
Like how are we present ourselves to the
world or what we're trying to say.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just the ring card girl thing is an odd
thing.
It's,
and it's weird when you have an all
female organization,
all female fighters,
but yet you still have girls holding up
the cards
should go with dudes.
Well I'll,
I'll bring that up,
but I'm pretty sure Shannon wouldn't be
unborn sage northcutt looking young
fellows tram.
See,
and the thing is though,
you,
when you think about it though,
we think combat has been
so sexualized and stuff like that.
It wouldn't be out of the norm.
No.
But at the same time,
what are you even talking about it?
We laugh,
right?
Cause it shocks our sensibilities a
little something.
We're not used to that.
That's weird.
So it's,
I mean,
what,
what did you think about females when
they first started fighting him?
A man.
What'd you think about female fighting?
Like?
Well,
I had a chance to watch tough enough in
Vegas.
Don't remember the event,
but nick the goat,
Thompson was on the card and there was
this,
uh,
undercard fight between these two women
and these gals went to war and we were
in the front row and it was just chaos.
I wish I could remember who was
fighting,
but it was such a wild and crazy fight
that at the end of the fight,
everyone in the arena was his standing
up,
screaming and cheering and clapping.
And I was with Eddie Bravo and we were
both like,
dude,
I'm a fan of women fighting now.
I love it.
And what did you,
not before,
like what was that just you had to see
them actually in action doing,
I guess being on that level or did you
just,
it just wasn't on your,
on your radar before that
there wasn't enough of it to really
compare what you had to see it,
you know,
you have,
it has to be presented to you.
Now I'm obviously a huge fan of it,
but you have to see it.
It's like we really,
we weren't really exposed to it because
it wasn't in the UFC.
So you'd have to go out and seek it.
And this is,
you know,
pre strike force.
So it just wasn't something that people
were,
were aware of and it wasn't like,
you know,
when you first started fighting and
you're talking about trying to get a
fight just wasn't that prevalent.
Right?
Yeah.
No,
I think that it wasn't,
I mean women didn't even know they could
fight.
Yeah.
You know,
and at a certain time.
So it's like shifting the attention to
that when you can actually watch these
dudes who are fighting,
you know,
you don't have to think of that on your
radar.
You don't have to seek that out.
If you're actually seeing fights,
unless it's given to your list,
presented to you,
you know,
then why,
why would it be on the radar?
Just think of it.
Women finding was also in my mind,
connected to a certain sense of
frustration for the athletes that they
had.
Like Lucy,
a riker could never get Christy Martin a
fighter.
You know,
there was always that thing.
Like I'd always known lucy a Ryko was
like the best women boxer and everybody
kind of knew,
but she couldn't get that fight like
where everybody would know how good she
was.
And then everybody's like,
oh Cristina Martins,
the best female box.
I'm like God damn it.
No,
she's not like you got to,
she's got to fight this woman from
Holland,
you know.
And then to sort of never happened.
And then you know there was mia st John
who was more like a girls,
a good boxer and she was cute and she
was really working that angle.
And then there's Laila Ali of course who
was Muhammad Ali's daughter,
but there was no one who caught fire.
There was no one,
there was no like,
oh my God,
this girl is going to fight this fight.
This is going to it.
Like what we have now,
like what we have now in MMA is
incredibly unique.
You know like Valentina Shevchenko and
Amanda Nunez did is just to super high
level MMA fighters who happened to be
women who have worked their way up the
ladder.
Amanda Nunez is obviously the champion.
Valentina though is just knocking on
that fucking door.
And that is an exciting dynamic matchup
for the women's bantamweight title that
didn't exist in boxing.
Right.
There was never that sort of match up
buildup thing.
And by the way,
there's other people waiting pass
Valentino,
you know there's,
there's,
there's contenders,
it's real and there's contenders at
Straw weight as well.
It's real.
And so I think that there was always
this sort of thing there was connected
with women fighting like that.
It wasn't legit,
but it was kind of like the w nba isn't
as good as,
as an athlete as some of those players
are.
No one gives a fuck in this country.
It just doesn't catch on.
You know,
I'm sure they give a fuck in the,
probably mad at that.
I'm saying that.
But
you mean marketing wise for some,
for whatever reason it wasn't seen as a,
it's not seen as an equal sphere to the
NBA.
Right.
And what's been unique about female
fighters in MMA is that because they can
share the same octagon on the same night
because they're in the same playing
field.
Then there's a,
there's a chance to see more of an equal
setting.
Oh,
100% yeah.
I think that's hugely important.
I mean,
when you have someone like Rhonda Rousey
who's headlining,
I am massive card and the paper view
sells 1.5
million buys.
That is gigantic for women's combat
sport,
for combat sports in general and it's
unprecedented.
Anybody who says it's not,
it's crazy.
There.
Before Ronda Rousey came along,
there had never been an athlete like
that that had been dominating in a
combat sport in on a worldwide scale
where everybody knew who she was.
Let's say it's totally uncharted.
Terry,
she was,
she was the mainstream appeal of it
somehow with what she presented.
Well,
she's an incredible person,
but for with what she presented,
she,
she had the,
the package that that transcended over.
This is a female fighter.
It was Ronda Rousey as a fighter and of
course they focused on her femininity.
They focused on her being a female,
but at the same time,
I mean she was doing way better than the
men when it came to universal appeal and
stuff like that.
Like there was something that she
crossed,
well,
she was a unique thing
is this unique thing.
Yeah.
And I think that that just did not
exist.
I mean,
Gina Carano sorta caught it a little
bit,
but she was gone before it really caught
fire,
you know?
And then when she lost a Cyborg,
there was a,
there was a lot of like weird feelings
about that because there's all these
speculations as Cyborg was on drugs and
then they looked at Gina Carano and she
was all beat up afterwards.
And that left is sort of weird taste in
people.
I understand that.
And I think that,
um,
around their eyes are tasty.
Um,
no,
I think that there's something to that.
I think,
um,
it's unfortunate because I'm like,
I know Chris Cyborg,
you know,
I was the matchmaker,
within victim when she was fighting for
us.
And I,
I was there for her weight cuts and I
saw some of her struggles and,
and what,
uh,
kind,
kind person,
she is just a genuinely kind person.
But then there's this persona of
toughness and her saying this kind of
thing to Rondo or she's saying this to
Gina and then they're sending it back
and it's this,
that,
you know,
and it just like for some reason,
um,
I never thought she got the,
the respect that was due,
but at the same time,
then she did fail a drug test.
So it was like,
ah,
like
unfortunately you carry the burden of
having your entire legacy be questioned
when you mess up like that.
But we know what the human body,
it looks like,
you know,
you know what a female body looks like
and you know what someone looks like
when they most likely have been
introducing male hormones into a female
body.
I don't,
I,
you know,
I understand what you're saying because
we know what we think is normal or what,
you know,
what a female body is like.
But I would say that,
uh,
we know what a male body looks like to
yeah.
Without hormones and we,
yeah,
and I mean,
you look at somebody who's like perfect
physique,
sage northcutt.
I mean it is everybody's speculating
the,
he's on steroids because he looks a
certain way.
Cause I,
I met the kid when he was a kid and he
looked like that.
The problem that line of thinking is
that he's a male.
Right.
And then he has natural testosterone and
then you can accentuate natural
testosterone pretty significantly,
especially if you're someone like a
Kevin randleman.
Right.
Or you know,
like a,
a Marvin Eastman who just has this
extreme mesomorphic bill.
There's a lot of people that are built
that way that don't do anything illegal.
There's not a lot of women that are,
yeah,
I,
you know,
again,
when we do the eye test like that,
like I,
I completely understand that my,
um,
I guess I wanted to believe of course,
that I wanted to believe that Cyborg was
drug free.
And now I believe that she is,
I believe that she's not currently,
yeah,
I believe that she's,
whatever happened in that time in 2011
she has rectified it.
She's passed all of her,
I guess something happened.
I'm not really because it was with the
UFC with some kind of task,
but it turned out it was with her birth
control pills or something.
What kind of behind him?
Yeah.
Something happened with her birth can or
something,
something happened there,
but
notes,
spironolactone,
which is a dht inhibitor with
dihydrotestosterone inhibitor that is
used for a bunch of different reasons.
It's used as a,
um,
it's used as a diuretic.
It's used for people combating the
effects of anabolic steroids for females
combating the effect.
It's used for cysts.
It's used for a bunch of different
possible reasons to use it.
Right?
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
cause I think I've known someone who's
been on that for cystic acne before,
so I understand.
I don't understand what happened in all
of that.
And I would love to,
I need to read about it.
I,
I'd love to know more about it.
It wasn't my,
in my sphere of interest.
Exactly.
Right.
Right,
right.
But you know,
pre 2011 drug test,
I wanted to believe she was natural
because I wanted to believe in her and
believe that somebody could be that
vicious and ferocious and wonderful like
that and take it,
take the idea of women fighting to a
different level.
And when she tested positive for,
for the,
um,
it was a d stands yes.
Stands something in $2,011
a wall.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
and then I was just,
I was heartbroken because first of all,
you know,
it was just like,
there was this,
I didn't believe anymore.
And then I got,
I got to meet her actually in
professional setting and I got to know
her as a person.
And you realize that when you know
people,
it's a lot more new on student,
I believe in you as a person and not,
you know what,
you know what I mean?
Like I believed in a lot of guys that
turned out to be taken steroids.
Yeah.
And it's,
yeah,
it's weird to associate,
I guess.
I never,
well you're a nice person.
You're kind what you wish for the best.
I do,
but I also wish for the best for women
all the time and that we're not going to
mess up,
but if everybody's got a message for
women,
wouldn't you definitely want to take a
hard stance against someone who's
introducing male hormones into a female
body and that you know,
they'll also,
the problem that is lot of the effects
are permanent,
like the,
a lot of the effects of a woman altering
her physiology with male hormones.
There's a certain amount of those
effects and this is also argued against
men taking steroids.
There's a certain amount and there's
been tests about this.
This isn't just speculation that certain
amount of physiological changes are
permanent.
When you take steroids because you're
introducing these hyper human levels of
testosterone to a mail system and things
change,
bone density changes,
the shape of your body changes,
the did tendon strength changes,
right,
and your testicles shrink and certainly
cause you,
you don't have the ability to like,
yeah,
that comes back like the,
the testicular atrophy.
It's like it's really the shutdown of
the endocrine system,
but that comes back and when it comes
back,
there's a certain amount of the
improvements that you've received
because of the steroids that you will
keep forever.
So even when you're in that exact post
steroid area.
Yeah,
which is one of the things that
infuriates people that have been cleaned
their whole life is that someone can
test positive and then they continue on
their career.
Even if they're not taking steroids now
they have a,
a benefit.
They have a permanent benefit of taking
those illegal drugs.
That sucks.
Yes.
I mean it's,
I mean there's nothing I can say like
that would champion that being a good
thing.
It's not a good thing.
But I will say that like,
she did not test positive the entire,
you know,
since 2011 and so if there was that
advantage in something like that,
we saw somebody like you bearish and
kickboxing still work against that and
still find victory.
So I,
I don't know
when should someone have to work against
that?
First of all,
there's Eurena barge fight was a
testament to cyborgs.
Courage.
And and fighting spirit that she took
that fight because nobody wanted a fight
Joanna for a long time.
And if you don't know who Julian a barge
is,
if you watch her Moitai fight,
she's some ungodly number of fights
she's had.
She's a multiple time world champion and
she's just so stunningly technical as a
fighter.
But you know,
you look at them physically,
they look very,
very different.
You know,
beside Borg is just this attacker
berserker style and fought a very good
fight against girl that nobody wanted to
fight.
It was a wonderful,
fantastic fight.
One of those fights even in in a loss
like her stock came out.
Yes.
Cyborg things.
I hate her.
Look I,
I think she's awesome.
I'm a fan and I tweeted this many times
along that the UFC needs to make 145
pound women's division,
but there's also some realities that you
have to address and those realities have
to be addressed for the other women that
haven't done anything as well to still
look up for them.
I,
I think you're right about that.
I think that when people test positive
I,
that the,
the penalties
have to be harsh.
They have to be hard.
And I don't know what's going on with
the new testing and stuff like that.
I'm not,
I don't,
I'm not in the know when it comes to the
UFC,
I'm no longer on a team,
you know what I mean?
It's like everything I do,
I've read through MMA media now,
so,
um,
I don't know who's testing one and
what's going on,
but I will say that the men had been
doing it for so long as well.
So should men who were clean have to
have fought against men who were dirty?
Very good question.
A lot of people think they shouldn't.
Yeah.
So I don't know what we do about clean
slating at,
at this point.
And it's also,
is it the same thing?
Is a man taking male hormones the same
as a woman taking male hormone already
has the male hormones,
right?
Wouldn't that be even more of an
increase than a woman taking?
Cause if a woman,
I mean,
no.
Okay.
No,
because a woman's adjusting her
physiology and becoming masculine,
whereas a man is becoming more
masculine.
There's a,
which is a shift literally in the body
structure that happens to women when
they start taking testosterone.
That's why a transgender man goes from a
woman to a man.
All such grows a beard,
right?
Chaz Bono changes the shape of your
face,
changes the tone of your voice,
your voice gets deeper.
I mean,
so many different factors play in it.
it's really depends on,
there's no,
there's also,
there's a rainbow or a broad spectrum of
dosages.
Like who knows how much you're taking,
how long you're taking it for.
And then there's also massive negative
consequences health wise for women.
That's what's,
I mean,
it's already hell on your body to fight.
Um,
and it's hell on your body to be a
female athlete in many ways.
It's wonderful and encouraging,
but you're right.
And I,
I again,
I don't have an answer for that.
I don't think there's a clean slate.
I do think that Cris Cyborg is in the
position right now with our career and
with the things have been questioned
about are the things that have been
done.
She has actually opportunity now to
really spearhead making it all clean and
coming,
you know,
coming forward with whatever happened in
the past with the spiritual,
I forgot the name of [inaudible],
all of that,
but that was concerned because it's not
really a performance enhancing drug.
The spironolactone is not going to,
it's not performance enhancing style.
It wasn't a failed test then.
It was not prohibited or it is
prohibited.
But she could get a,
uh,
therapy therapeutic use exemption.
They did.
She,
I think she did it achieve,
they're doing that or in the process of
trying to do that,
maybe it has been cleared.
What that means is,
look,
it's not hurting anybody she competes
against.
It's not that it's just,
they don't like people taking it because
it can mask some of the effects of
Androgens in,
in the female body.
And it also,
um,
as a diuretic.
Diuretics are illegal because diuretics
also can mask some of the potential
properties of testosterone or hormones
or they did away with all the ivy.
Rehydration is only person who liked ivy
and rehydration.
You're the only one.
I think there's a lot of people like to
live.
I mean I was clean.
I hate to say that I was clean my whole
life but I was po possibly because
nobody ever offered me anything.
If somebody offered you steroids you
thing you would have taken it.
I don't know.
I look back now and I'm like,
I wonder how many other women anyway.
Yeah.
What if it was back in the day like the
wild west,
like pride days,
like pride days where the wild west,
like during pride,
like I talked to [inaudible] in any way
he dealt,
he described about his con is contract
literally in capital letter said we will
not test you for steroids and answer was
laughing about it and was like fucking
everybody was on shit back then.
Did that question I think I probably
would have if I'd have been offered it.
I don't know.
But then you think about that and then
you think about,
okay,
2011 was just on the cusp of being the
wild west.
Right.
So if she did take steroids,
if she was on something,
isn't that just what everybody else was
trying to do?
Some people were,
I don't think Gina was doing it.
Gina Carano Gina did it at all.
No,
some women definitely did for shooting.
I mean,
you look at the old pictures that the
fighters,
the generation before me,
and I'm not throwing out accusations,
I'm just saying people with Musculature,
like,
like Becky,
Levi and people like that.
You kind of wonder like,
okay,
how much of that was,
you know?
Well,
I know girls that just compete in Jiu
Jitsu tournaments,
that dues test,
test testosterone.
I mean,
they just want to be stronger and better
and there's no money in it.
They're just trying to get an edge.
And it's kind of weird.
You know,
it's,
it's weird.
It's,
you know,
they're,
it's amateur and no one's testing and
they say everyone's doing it so they're
doing it.
So you go,
okay,
look,
I've got no position on this.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know what to say,
but when it comes to mma and when it
comes to professional sports,
and back then,
if it was the wild west,
I'm sure a lot of people were doing it,
you know?
But Chris Cyborg became sort of the
poster girl when she looked the part and
then tested positive.
I mean,
what do we do with that now?
That's a good question.
What do we do it,
because the guidebook,
I think she's a phenomenal woman.
I think she's a kind and good woman and
a wonderful fighter for people to look
up to.
So I don't,
I don't know what you do with that now.
I think that what has to go on the table
is just,
we take everything by what happens
today.
And if a person doesn't test positive,
we take them at their word.
The real problem though,
with what's going on today as they're
offering these massively steep,
steep sentences for people and
suspensions for people.
So like first if you get caught,
I think the first suspension is like two
years and that if you get caught again
it's even deeper and then three years,
it's three times.
If you get caught a third time,
it's like life,
like Vander Lee silver one is the most
disturbing one to me because he ran away
from a test and they banned him for
life.
Like die is fucking,
that's abusive.
Yeah.
You gotta wonder how many other fighters
have run away from it but it just wasn't
as public like you know.
Sure it will.
Not only that,
but when you talk to chill son and about
how sketchy the Usada people were when
they came to him,
like they made them do it in a broom
closet and give boys like this is this
sterile?
Like who are you?
Do you have an id?
Like they don't even,
they don't want to give you ID.
They just want to test right away and
you just have to listen to them.
In the case of him where they may be
trying to hawk.
I am a little bit more just because of
his past shown,
but it is,
um,
I don't know.
I don't know when it comes to
regulation,
who regulates the regulators?
Like that is the question,
right?
The question.
Yeah.
But at the same time,
we don't want this taken away from us.
Right.
Like this whole thing that the,
the moments of passion,
the Darren Elkins moments,
we don't want that taken away from us.
And to have that soured by knowing that
that person was cheating was cheating.
You know,
it's,
I think there's a huge emotional
investment to see a clean sport.
Well,
how about the greatest of gray areas,
which is Vito Belfort.
Yeah.
They let them,
yeah,
they let them,
I mean,
who is a testosterone use exemption and
when he was doing it,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
He looked terrified.
He looked like 19 year old beach.
Yeah.
Crazier than 19 year old.
But he looked like a demon.
I mean,
Vito would come out and just starch.
Everybody was smashing people.
We'll kick luke rockhold when we never
seen him throw a wheel in his life.
He threw two wheel kicks in his entire
career.
Oh look at the pictures of him.
This is 2007 on the left in 2000 or 2012
and the left and 2017 on the right.
Yeah.
Fucking a
that poor guy though.
Can you imagine being on that level?
I mean you do,
you take testosterone.
Yeah.
So can you imagine being on that level
where you feel like your body is in a
certain,
it can perform a certain way and then
have that taken away from you and then
like just having to compete with that
and then compete with whatever's going
on in your mind too?
Well,
there's the thing is that with youth is,
you know,
you have all this athletic ability,
you have all the strength and speed,
but you don't have any experience and
wisdom.
And then as you gain experience and
wisdom,
father time slowly takes away your
physical gifts to the point where you're
trying to,
like Bernard Hopkins when he fought Joe
Smith,
there was that weird moment where you
realize like,
oh,
we've passed the point here where your
knowledge and your hard work and
discipline makes up for the fact that
your body's deteriorating.
Right.
Then you're fighting this young bulldog
who's just an animal.
He went through the ropes.
Yeah,
he fell on his head.
It was horrible.
The meeting really made me think about
like the way boxing rings are set up.
Like how the fuck is it?
So easy to fall through the ropes and
why or why is there no one there to see
that happening and catch them like he
fell on his head,
didn't know where the fuck he was,
didn't know what was going on.
So dangerous.
So dangerous when you get a died there.
The way he fell back to,
he literally fell head first and landed
on the ground and I'm assuming it was
concrete,
I mean,
and didn't know what happened.
Didn't know where he was thought he got
pushed out of the ring,
didn't know he got knocked out.
It was just so out of it.
Yeah.
They,
there comes the time when we have to
recognize our mortality and
unfortunately fighters are not people to
do that.
Then you look too,
yeah.
She didn't have to recognize it for a
couple of years.
Yeah.
The turn back the time,
I mean you went from Vitor Belfort who
fought rich Franklin Vito Belfort who
fought a sexy yama and you know,
you look good.
But then when he got on the
testosterone,
it's like all of a sudden you have the
phenom,
this,
this demon
that,
that a therapeutic use exemption stuff
that it seemed to spike a certain time
for a lot
of people.
Why is that found out?
It was legal.
It was a bunch of shitty.
As doctors.
I know some people who use some shady
ass doctors and what the doctor would
literally tell them is you take
testosterone for a short amount of time,
take a lot of it,
um,
get your system hooked on it,
then get off of it and then get tested.
So then they will go,
man,
just got low testosterone.
It's because your body,
you jolted it down with like 10 weeks of
high level test and then you say,
I'm feeling a little run down and maybe
I have something wrong with me.
I have a medical condition.
It's like a lot of it was just guys who
take steroids and their body had stopped
producing it naturally and then they got
a therapeutic use exemption and they
were shooting it up all the time and
then they were going in there and
they're 27 years old.
So the benefits of the previous steroid
use didn't linger to the point that,
or was it a mental thing?
Well,
the benefits there,
if they,
if their endocrine system
caught up,
say say if they did a certain amount of
cycles and they gained a certain amount
of strength there,
they would come.
They would keep some of that benefit
permanently.
But when their end to consistent crashed
because they had taken all the stores
and then they got off of it,
that's when they can test and the test
shows low testosterone.
That's all they needed to show.
They didn't,
didn't need.
She could still physically perform to a
higher level than they could have if
they've never done steroids in the first
place
probably.
But while they're at a low testosterone,
they're gonna experience very
significant decreases in endurance and
stamina and your,
your intensity,
all that's going to be down.
Your body's like really depressed.
Like that's one of the things that
happens to men when they get head
injuries is that head injuries and
traumatic brain injuries cause a
disruption in the pituitary gland,
which causes your body to produce less
testosterone,
which oftentimes leads to soldiers,
football players,
fighters becoming severely depressed and
oftentimes they lane towards alcoholism
and drug addiction.
And a lot of that is trying to combat
that depression.
I actually,
that that makes a great deal of sense.
I was never tested to the extent of
this,
but when I,
when I quit fighting,
I was put on estrogen because I have a
really messed up reproductive system
from,
I don't know if I was like,
it's,
I have polycystic ovarian syndrome,
which it,
it's anyway,
whatever it is.
I was put on a birth control pill with
very high estrogen and that led me to
have to go on antidepressants,
which led me have to go into this,
which I mean it,
yeah,
it was just the amount of estrogen
leads.
You do what?
I wanted to have babies really badly and
um,
I had horrible not to be,
to put whatever we're talking about.
Everything.
While I was,
while I was fighting,
I um,
I had horrible periods.
Like I would have periods for an entire
month and stuff like that while I was
fighting.
Yeah.
Like when my body fat lowered for
whatever reason,
you know,
women are supposed to stop and they,
they're supposed to intern men or it,
you know,
but for me it was different and I would,
I was just like,
I was bleeding all the time.
Like it was a,
it was a long 10 years,
but he's just like,
I,
you know,
like my body was really,
really weird.
And so when I stopped fighting I was
like,
I was,
I was sick of being in pain.
I was sick of this and that.
I was like,
I don't have to.
Um,
I didn't want to put any chemicals into
my,
when I was fighting,
I was really worried about that,
like worried about if that would make me
gain weight if I went on the birth
control pill or something like that,
you know?
So when I quit fighting,
you know,
I went to a gynecologist and she put me
on it and then it just,
I crashed,
I don't know which birth control pill it
was,
but I was severely depressed when I quit
fighting the birth control pills cause
depression irregulated regulated.
I don't know if eight caused depression,
but I would say that the changing
chemicals in my body post fight so I
could,
you can't just say it's like this one
thing,
but I would say heightened estrogen
probably.
I was all of a sudden eating carbs again
for the first time and for,
you know what I mean?
A lot of things were different.
I wasn't exercising however many hours a
day.
Everything in my life was different.
But I will say,
you know,
I put on 30 pounds within six months of
retiring like it.
Yeah,
it was insane.
I mean,
I have breasts zone,
which is a great thing,
but it wasn't something I was used to
for a decade.
And um,
you know,
it's um,
it's so funny about how when your,
your reproductive chemicals or when all
that gets messed up,
how that actually messes with your brain
as well.
Because I can understand these men
coming off of of head injuries.
If they're having a decreased like a
chemical like testosterone or whatever
it is,
I can understand that actual weirdness
like taking part and that affecting
their brains severely in the shutdown of
the steroid cycles is a lot of,
Gosh,
depression.
It's led people to suicide.
And if you're inclined towards
depression in the first place,
I'm sure it probably,
it gets accentuated.
Oh,
oh yeah.
There's a big history of depression in
my family.
I went through a really rough time.
Um,
and then remarkably I discovered writing
and that was great and it's led me on a
completely different path.
But yeah,
a post fighting,
there's something about that.
It's not even,
I mean,
think the chemicals are a great,
I'm not a doctor and I'm not a
scientist.
That's my family.
They're all scientists and shit.
I don't,
I don't know any of it.
Like I don't know the science behind it
exactly.
But I will say that,
that,
um,
I don't know that it's necessarily
always chemical.
I think that there's a big part of it.
It's also purposeful.
I think when you don't have a purpose
and you don't have a goal and something
to strive for,
then your body reacts to it as well and
your brain reacts to that as well.
So I think that as well.
Yeah,
I think that's something exercise thing
too.
I'm sure that played a big factor.
The lack of exercise or the much greatly
reduced,
you know,
different,
you can run three miles a day,
but it's not the same as sparring every
other day or whatever you're doing.
Or do,
you know,
doing Jujitsu twice a day or whatever it
is.
Yeah.
So much of probably what depression is,
is so many,
it's just a giant combination of factors
I think.
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
I'm not,
I'm not as,
I have a great therapist,
but I'm not,
you know,
I can't tell you what that is.
I,
but I can't say that,
um,
there is something to having all of that
in balance.
Um,
having,
being chemically,
I guess physiologically in balance with
the way your body's supposed to be and
then have your,
um,
exercise the way it's supposed to be.
And then have your purpose the way it's
supposed to be.
And it's such a weird balance as human
beings that when any of you have these
things get thrown out of whack,
you're headed for trouble and
friendships,
family,
all the relationships that you
keep in your life.
I saw this really interesting clip from
this guy and he was talking about is a,
I'm a rapper.
I think he was,
but he's talking about his mental diet
and the way he looked at it.
It's like that people are really
concentrating constantly about what they
eat,
but they're not concentrating constantly
about what they take in their mind and
that like you should really be aware of
your mental diet too.
You know that if you snack on too much
junk food,
mentally it will weaken your mind,
you know?
Like,
yeah,
that makes sense.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
I think that we don't push ourselves
mentally a lot and when it comes to
that,
I think honestly it's just coming down
to it.
I mean,
it's not a cure all that reading,
if you just read,
if you just sit and force yourself to
read and you actually engage with
attacks,
all of a sudden you realize something is
happening in your brain.
You're creating space for more thought
in your brain,
but also you can't be exposed to too
much bullshit.
And who knows what's bullshit and what's
not balls.
I mean,
there has to be a discernment somewhere
along the line,
some sort of like,
uh,
I guess,
um,
I don't know.
Literary consciousness or something like
that where you know that,
I mean,
I'm addicted to twitter,
but,
oh,
I love twitter.
I love it.
And I know that I'm a giant bitch on
there and I don't do your,
I am,
oh,
you a bitch.
I'm always telling people to go fuck
themselves.
Oh,
it's like game because it's so enjoyable
to me.
It's like playing a game.
And I,
you know,
the part of me is like,
I hate that part of myself,
but I also really like it because I
think I'm be coming.
It's to me,
it's not really,
I'm not a brand.
There's no Julie Kedsey fighter who has
to impress anybody anymore like it.
You know,
there's a,
granted I represent invicta to a certain
extent,
but I know I fully understand that
Shannon could fire me if I say something
just outrageous and horrible.
She wouldn't,
she's a wonderful person and I'm no
longer at behind the scenes there.
I'm just,
I'm a commentator.
I'm not somebody making any decisions
with the company.
Right.
But I don't know,
when it comes to twitter,
what do you do?
You get in flame wars with people.
Some street shit too.
Yeah.
I kind of enjoy when people insult me
and I go after.
Yeah.
But I do feel my brain deteriorating a
little bit when they do that.
You know?
It was just like I would,
I,
I know.
It's just like,
okay,
I need to stop me to put this down now.
But you know,
when they come at me and they're just
like,
you're a Feminazi your this who I'm just
yeah,
come on up.
Feminine.
I'm very outspoken.
Being a feminist.
I'm very,
you know,
and when I talk about socialism,
when I talk about I hate Donald Trump
and I talk about this,
you know,
and Yep,
I would never label you in like you're
just a genuine person.
Like who happens to be a woman who
believes what you believe.
Like you,
you're not like sexist.
You're not like anti male or anytime.
Man,
I,
I love men,
I believe settle down.
But the thing is,
um,
I am pro woman to certain sent me when
it comes to mma,
I'm,
I'm more interested in what's going on
with women in the sport then with men.
That's just where I'm oriented.
That's part of your job.
And um,
but well,
I don't know,
there's this association though.
First of all,
the whole Feminazi label is just,
I mean,
that's the first thing.
Like I said,
yeah,
I'm really proud to be a feminist.
And then people are just know that means
you hate,
you think they're all rapists.
And I'm like,
no,
that discredits men so much.
Like why?
No.
Well,
it's silly.
And that though the term feminist has
been so cooptive by negative thoughts.
So many people have this negative
connotation they attached to it,
of course,
and its movements that,
you know,
third wave feminist and this and you
know,
there's certain when whenever the real
fucking problem,
male feminists,
they've ruined it.
Those fucking twats men ruin everything
they've read even ruined.
That's funny.
I know,
I know Jamie was on here and he was a
friend of mine and something weird
happened with that guy.
I don't know what's going on with his
life right now that I don't know what
Scott and I don't want it like
speculate,
any of that.
But we were really good friends for a
while and you know,
I know his like he was very disliked as
a male feminist,
quote unquote male.
Well it's because everybody thought that
he was what he just got accused of being
right and they're just coonhounds that
are taking that angle.
That is an interesting track.
Honestly think sometimes people are just
assholes who want sex.
And I also think sometimes people are
manipulative assholes who want sex.
I don't see him as a manipulative
person,
but again,
I might probably not,
I didn't interact.
Yeah,
I don't know either.
You know,
I don't,
I think people are a bunch of different
things depending on who they are,
what time of the day.
I think it'd be nice if the whole world
was egalitarianism and if we all looked
at people as just treating them,
who they are based on their character
and their personality and not
categorizing them.
So specifically like,
oh you are a woman so you are less or
you are a man and you are moving
or,
or vice averse,
a male feminist.
And I'm like,
that's the problem.
I mean,
are you joking when you say no?
yeah,
it's,
the problem is there's a lot of people
that virtue signal and a lot of people
that are posturing and a lot of people
that are putting a label on themselves
to try to make themselves seem like
they're in a higher moral high ground
than the rest of the folks around them.
And that's the motivation for doing it.
That becomes transparent and people get
angry at that.
They recognize what it is,
so when someone like Jamie Kilstein
slips up after all these years of
virtual signaling,
they're like,
ah,
I knew it.
You fuck,
here's that.
Does that really negate some of the good
things that he's done?
If he's influenced some men?
I don't know the virtue.
I guess one of the good things,
I don't know if he's maybe said,
oh,
hey,
a woman is actually a person.
Yeah,
it's well,
absolutely full.
The fuck doesn't think a woman as a
person.
Twitter timeline,
those people,
if there's a person out there that
doesn't think that a woman's a person
fucking Jamie Kilstein is not going to
change their opinion.
It's just going to,
he's just going to broadcast it and let
everybody know that's how he thinks and
he's going to get all this love and
people are going to send them all these
likes and they're going to give them a
thumbs up and say nice things to him on
twitter and that may
or may not be a good thing.
It's more a good thing that a bad thing.
It's not a bad thing,
but you're not going to change.
Some asshole opinion saying something
like that.
I don't know that you are,
but I,
I don't know.
Have you changed any assholes
opinion with any group things that if
you've come out and said something,
have you,
do you think you've changed people's
opinions?
I think things change if they value what
you're saying,
if they believe that you're being
truthful and if what you're saying is
compelling enough for them to reconsider
the way they look at things,
it is possible,
but it's not 100% and that's not the
motivation behind doing things in the
first place.
I'm not trying,
I don't ever try to change people's
opinions,
but I do try to express myself as
cleanly and as accurately and as
honestly as I can.
And I think that in my opinion,
in my experience,
when I've heard people like you talking
about your life,
like you just talking about your life in
this podcast,
I take that in and I know it's pure and
it'll make me consider every little,
every thing that a person says.
Every sentence,
every conversation that you have with
someone where they're being real with
you,
it adds more knowledge to your database
of human interaction and the way people
behave and think.
Now thinking that way,
it does slowly make you consider more
things about people and that adds to the
overall surface area of knowledge that
you have about people in general.
I absolutely do.
You in your position because you have
considerable influence.
Do you worry about having people kind of
latch on things,
hive minded and,
and,
and go a direction that you feel a
responsibility I guess to people,
but definitely feel responsibility and
not manipulating them and it definitely
feel responsibility and not taking
advantage of that and not starting a
cult or something like that.
Yeah.
I mean,
but it's,
the good part about it is if you don't
need anything from anybody,
like you're not trying to get people to
send you $50 a month for the fucking,
you know,
platinum plan where you got access to
the secret messages,
l Ron Hubbard or whatever.
Yeah.
But you know what I mean?
It's like you can take advantage of
people in certain ways and I think that
the,
that's a,
that's a real issue with any sort of
hive mind thinking.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't know where I get,
I this,
this is fascinating.
I,
I guess religion and things like that
always troubled me and,
and that hive mind mentality that,
that,
that troubles me.
It troubles me that,
I mean to be honest,
it troubles me that Alex Jones was on
hair or somebody who,
who kind of leads that sort of thing.
Yes.
But
when Alex Jones is on here,
I think people got to understand Alice
Jones way more after me getting him
drunk and stoned and have a talk about
interdimensional child molesters.
Like you get to see a chair like,
oh this is kind of like half wacky show
or he's also commenting on the craziness
of the world.
But you got to see who he really is.
What I,
the guy that I've known for almost 20
years,
like that's what I wanted to do.
By having them on,
like people are like,
why are you friends with that guy?
I'm like,
watch,
watch what happens.
We'll get them fucked up.
We're going to have some fun.
And you realize like,
oh,
this guy's like,
he's kind of wacky.
Like half of what he's doing is almost
like a show.
Right?
Well it's like isn't it is and that's
kind of him.
People are buying into that,
but what are they buying into that's
false and what are they buying into?
That's true.
Unfortunately a lot of what Alex Jones
has been presenting over these years is
actually true.
Like agent provocateurs.
Like when they have peaceful protest,
they'll send in people to smash windows
and they're wearing government issue
boots and they get rounded up and they
don't wind up being prosecuted because
they were literally brought in by the
police to turn a peaceful protest into a
violent protest.
Like the people that took over occupy
Wall Street and undercover cops that
were doing all this fucking crazy,
chaotic,
violent shit to get people to move in
and break up these camps and break up
these protests when they were all legal.
Alex Jones sort of expose all that
first puts his support and I don't want
to be,
I actually don't want to be in this
word.
I'm not trying to be controversial,
honestly.
I'm just like,
no,
it's all conversation expression.
When he puts his support behind people
like Donald Trump,
who is actually pushing these sorts of
agendas,
what sorts of the anti protesting,
like trying to change the law so that
you can run over protesters when there
peacefully protest and things like that.
I don't know that he's changing the
laws,
but these things are coming up.
What does that,
it's something a,
it's Wisconsin or Michigan.
There's something like that.
They're trying to put a thing in two
states at whatever it is.
Yeah,
I know and I,
I'm so bad because when I follow my
train of thought and I can never have
citations and it drives me bananas
because I don't want to present
information as speculation.
The people are trying to stop people
from violating other people's rights.
Right.
But is a person's right to drive a car
down the street more important than a
person's right to express themselves by
saying,
I don't want this to happen.
I am willfully challenging the law right
here in a peaceful way,
but it's not peaceful.
If your GRANDPA's dying and you need to
get to the hospital and some asshole
wants to stand in front of him with a
macrame hat on with a,
you know,
I'm a male feminist sign.
Right.
What instance are you quoting?
Split.
We've been talking about blocking people
on the road.
It doesn't help anyone.
No,
it doesn't help anybody.
I mean,
I've been arrested for political
protests before and I was very aware.
I was crossing a line on to here I was
doing something.
I was going to be arrested for it,
but it was the voices behind me and the
collective voices together that we're
doing something not knowing that they
were going to be arrested.
Knowing that the part about going to
jail and being able to write about or
being able to understand that you were
taking a stance on something.
You're just trying to bring attention to
something that you think is wrong.
Well,
what were you arrested for?
Oh,
it was many years ago and all the
military guys already hate me,
but it was the school of the Americas.
I was 18.
I got arrested twice,
18 or 19.
Um,
it was a school of the Americas when
they were,
they were teaching the counterinsurgency
techniques,
um,
down at Fort Benning,
Georgia.
I'm banned for life there,
but it was very religious.
Then I was very into social justice.
I was really like,
I want it to be a nun and I wanted to
change the world and I wanted people to
not kill each other anymore.
And I wanted us not to fund a military
groups in South America who were
slaughtering people at the same time.
It was protesting.
I was stepping deliberately onto a
military base and saying,
no,
I don't want this to happen anymore.
I'm peaceful.
You're gonna go with you.
I,
you're arresting me.
I know my rights and the,
and the soldiers.
Let's
unpack that because what you did there
was,
you made a up,
there's a political protest.
You went to the scene of where you think
these terrible things are taking place
and you took a stand knowing you were
going to get arrested and that it was
going to bring media attention to this
[inaudible].
There's a big difference between that
and you deciding we're going to block
the one oh one because black lives
matter,
you know,
that doesn't have anything to do with
all those people that were driving to
work.
You're violating their rights to pass.
You're violating their space.
You're stopping them from being able to
move freely and a lot of them are
private deal of attention to it,
but you're doing it in a way that
inconveniences and puts people in danger
and it's not necessary.
You can do it in a public space.
You could do it in places where you're
allowed to protest.
You can do it and you could still get
your voice out and still get your
message out and not block traffic on the
highway.
The blocking traffic on the highways,
attention horing and it's attention
whoring in a very dangerous way because
you are stopping people from getting to
medication.
You're stopping people from getting
medical treatment.
Your people can be in the middle of
giving birth.
There's a lot of shit that happens.
We you,
you fuck with people's ability to travel
and move around,
we rely on that.
It's extremely significant.
So when you just decide that you know,
you,
whatever,
I want transgender rights for the
bathroom,
let's Bach this fucking highway.
Just because you think you can get
attention doing something like that
doesn't mean it's the right thing to do.
There are ways to get attention doing
things that are lawful and there's ways
that are noble and then there's blocking
the fucking highway like a baby.
Are they still working though?
I'm not just talking about the highway.
The are are,
are bringing attention to things.
I mean is that still working the Dakota
pipeline and stuff like that when people
were protesting in a peaceful way,
did it shut it down?
Shut it down.
But it just,
I mean it's bad for sas change.
It's not,
and I don't even know if that's the best
example of it.
And then I'm a good example
because it was peaceful protesting and
it did get a lot of attention,
including me and a lot of other people
who protest,
who tweeted about it and put a blinks
about it and let people know about and
talked about it on the podcast.
Yeah,
I mean it does get attention
when the tower hit.
I understand what you're saying.
Yeah.
Protesting.
They're disregarding what you're saying
about the highways and stuff like that
because that wouldn't be the kind of
protest that I would want it to be a
part of this not the kind of thing I
would want to enact.
Now did I believe in that?
Do I believe that the black lives matter
movement?
Yes,
to a certain extent.
I also believe in police officer
training and better training for police
officers and those in situations of high
stress.
I think that there's so much nuance to
what's going on there and there's so
much carried on and and the the highway
blocking and the stuff like that.
You're giving very,
very good counter arguments to,
to this,
but I will say that there's also
something in effect when you can make
the loudest noise and you know something
is wrong,
isn't it?
Your responsibility to try and fix
things,
not by stopping the highway.
Maybe not.
Maybe it's not.
So by stopping the highway,
but if people are so determined to be
against what you're saying,
there's so in rooted you people have to
make noise in the strangest ways.
They have to do what
people are very self righteous and they
think that you have to listen to them
and you don't want to listen to them.
No,
you don't.
Your right as an American to not have to
listen to someone's protest as much as
it's your right as an American,
a protest.
You can't force someone to listen to you
because you think you're right and
that's what you're doing by standing in
front of someone on the highway in
blocking their passage.
Okay.
But getting beyond the highway thing,
because again,
what you're bringing on,
did I have an issue with,
okay.
Okay.
We literally,
I have no problem with protesting I
think,
but when you're protesting on the
highway and you're blocking traffic,
you're a cunt.
I mean,
that's a shitty way to do it.
Right?
I,
I cannot disagree with you to a certain
extent where it is a very inconvenient
thing and it can be a dangerous thing
and I don't think any protesting should
endanger peoples lives at all.
By the way,
don't hate marathons too for the same
reason.
Yeah.
Well I mentioned,
makes a lot of sense,
but at least those are scheduled.
I don't think that that's um,
caused to be able to have the right to,
to run somebody over and kill me.
No,
no.
You shouldn't have the right.
Don't think somebody's life is not worth
something because they're expressing
themselves in a way that you disagree
with.
Debra does not necessarily what the law
is saying.
No law saying that you exonerate someone
responsibility.
If someone jumps in front of your car
and tries to stop,
we've seen he breaks off and smashed
their car windows because they're trying
to get through some sort of a protest
line and they don't have anything to do
with what the protest is.
They just want to get out of there.
I'm in their car and their stock and
maybe they have their kid with them and
the kids crying and freaking out and he
hit the gas.
Incredibly detailed.
This is an incredibly detailed example
of some of that.
I don't actually have the reference
point to,
I don't have a citation for this,
so I can't argue with you on any of the
story that you're giving me because I
have no way of knowing this,
this incident,
but I do think that your speculation is
correct in in the sense that I think
that no,
that would be horrible.
That would be horrible to have people
saying,
okay,
this means more to me.
Then you're getting your kid to your
sick kid to the hospital.
I think absolutely.
I think that that,
no,
I don't think that anybody's life is
worth more than another person's life.
What's also,
there's something going on where there's
a lot of misdirected rage and anger.
Like my friend was very angry.
My friend was at one of these things
where he was trying to get his car
through and they were all blocked and
stopped and people had crossed hands,
locked hands and blocked the highway and
some guy came up to his window and is
screaming,
black lives matter,
screaming at his window.
He's like,
yeah,
I agree man.
Okay,
I'm agree,
but I'm stuck in traffic.
Why are you yelling at me?
I'm not doing anything like you were
very angry right now.
He's like this white guy yelling at him,
another white guy and he's screaming
black lives matter at him.
It's like,
okay,
this is so misdirected.
If my friend is a Democrat,
votes liberal,
he's so,
so liberal,
like down the board with a pretty much
everything and someone's screaming at
him and screaming at him like he has
done something wrong because this person
is misguided and misdirected rage and
they're,
they're a part of this whole mob
mentality.
Everyone's together,
they're all chanting and yelling and
everyone's getting excited and they
think that they're doing the right
thing.
And these kids today,
a lot of them that are involved in these
protests,
they're so enamored by this idea that
they're doing the right thing.
They're enacting change.
They don't realize that they're also
polarizing
the opposition,
and this is one of the reasons why
Donald Trump was elected in the first
place because so many people are so
tired of people shoving in their phase,
they're righteous indignation shoving in
their face is locking hands and blocking
the highway and you have to listen to
us.
That is energy and it goes like this.
And then when it goes like that,
people go like that.
It's in and out.
There's a cycle.
And can you understand where the rage is
built up of?
People felt like they've been ignored
and they've been pushed back so hard
that they actually start exploding like
that and they get into these hives
because they have no other group to
belong to.
There's definitely a way that you could
see that there's definitely a way that
makes sense.
What is the appropriate way to do things
then to continue to write,
to continue to talk,
to continue to express yourself in a way
that's going to make other people
consider what you're saying and maybe
change people's minds and thoughts and,
and it's not an instantaneous thing.
It's not like you put up a sign and
everything's fixed.
No,
it's take society that right.
But I think that's part of the rage of
people screaming as they want it to
change now and by going up to my
friend's window and yelling,
black lives matter this fuck.
Head thinks he's going to change that,
but he doesn't even really think that.
He thinks he's got the right to do it
and you've got to fucking listen to me,
man.
There's this thing going on where people
get these mob mindsets where they think
they're allowed to hit a girl because
she's got a red hat on that says make
bitcoin great again.
Have you seen that video?
That poor girl got maced in the face?
It was a joe cat.
They may stir in the fucking face.
I get that.
I get what you're saying.
And I am,
I am on board with,
with the sentiment of what you're
saying.
I really do understand it,
but I also think there's such it,
a finger pointing going on and I'm
guilty of it on my twitter because I go
after these fuckheads all the tie.
They call it [inaudible].
You fell it Nazi.
And I say,
no,
fuck Donald Trump.
Seriously,
that person is not qualified to be
president.
Well is bad too.
I was like,
that's not,
I didn't say anything about him.
I said,
this person in office is not qualified.
He should step down.
Um,
but I am.
Can I really wanted to be president?
No,
I don't think he wanted to be president
at all.
No.
I think he's terrified.
He is a scared,
terrified little man up there.
Maybe he's not terrified.
Maybe he's crazy,
but he,
I don't think he wanted to do this.
It's just sort of happened.
Yeah,
I think,
I think he didn't think it through.
And I think that's when we're talking
about not thinking it through.
I think the guy screaming at your friend
in the window,
he's not thinking it through.
He's caught on to something.
He's caught up in a wave of some pen,
do it.
There's a million other people behind
them.
Everyone's screaming,
he's looking at my friend,
my friend's vulnerable,
my friends below him cause he's seated
and he's just screaming.
Black lives matter.
It's like,
yeah,
it's that bullshit.
But it's it,
it's awesome that twitter generation
protesting.
But it's also,
we have learned,
it's so hard to just generalize and say
everything is because of this and
everything is because of that,
isn't it?
Everything has to come from an
individual place.
And at the same time we're all trying to
belong to communities.
We're all trying to belong to something
we believe in.
Right.
And,
and we're latching onto that.
And then I think that the sins that have
in to the sins that we,
whatever then that happened along the
way,
the missteps that happened along the
we tend to forgive them instead of
pointing out,
no,
you shouldn't do this.
You shouldn't affect somebody who's
driving their child to work or something
like that,
that that's not what should happen.
But we do tend to forgive the people who
are in the same team as us.
Don't wait,
of course.
And that's where the the make America
great fuckers.
Sorry.
I think,
well anyway,
you do all that.
They can't see their team lose and
they'll defend him now to the death of
defend his decisions.
He does something wrong.
Well you don't understand how it works,
do you like?
No,
I actually had to understand how it
works.
This person is not supposed to be in
power.
This person's not supposed to represent
America.
This is an and and he is and he's not
who I want the world to see America as.
I think we're a great country and we
fuck up a lot.
There's also a problem when having a
popularity contest to decide who gets to
run things.
Imagine if they had a popularity contest
to get to see who's the dean of Harvard.
Yeah.
Like what's the character going to be
this year?
The curriculum is going to be
Jesus.
All right.
Welcome.
One will.
I mean that's what's going to be
happening right now.
We're going to do away with,
you know,
the public's,
all the vouchers and the shit that's
happening.
There's a lot of weird shit going on
that jeff sessions guy scares her shit.
Oh my God,
he wants to bring back,
just say no.
Yeah.
Must bring back to 19 he's just saying,
he just said,
and the marijuana has the same negative
effects as heroin language.
Slightly less bad than heroin.
What the Hell Dude,
like child,
an old child and it's,
yeah,
it's not good.
No,
And,
and I,
I,
cause I get worked up thinking about it,
these people in power and I got it.
As you get worked out and people get
worked up rather,
and they start talking about it and they
also realize that,
hey man,
it really does matter if you vote,
it really does matter if you're
politically active,
right?
It really doesn't matter if you talk
about these things that you care,
but the team mentality that we have,
the US versus them,
it just gets so weird.
It gets so fucking crazy.
People get so out of control with it and
they,
like you said,
the people that make America great
again,
people they don't want to hear shit
about the left.
They didn't want to shit about Bernie.
They want to say Barack Obama is a
Muslim and from fucking Kenya,
and I'm guilty of not wanting to know
good things about Donald Trump.
I don't want to know them.
I don't care.
I don't,
I don't care because I see so much.
You know?
It's just like there's so much that's
working against human achievement with
him being in power and the people he's
appointing.
Empower
is,
but I think it gives people goal.
I think it gives people like,
I think without opposition it's very
difficult to get motivated and I think
there's a significant amount of
opposition now and people were,
I think they're organizing people on the
left are organizing in a way that they
never had before and hopefully hopefully
people will understand that there'll be
someone along the line that understands
that the polarization effect that
happens between choosing these hard line
teams left and right and not recognizing
the possibility that there's so many
people in the middle that just pick a
side.
They just decided to go left or decide
to go.
Right.
And they could be on either side,
but both of them are unreasonable.
Both of them are unrealistic.
Yeah.
You know,
and yeah,
Hillary Clinton was a terrible
candidate.
She was a terrible opposition
Hopefully next time they'll be someone
that's really good and will understand
what is the problem with having a
medical maniacal egomaniac who was a
fucking a business vulture run,
run the country,
which happened.
I mean that was the choice.
This awareness,
I,
in my opinion,
she was more qualified.
She served as secretary of the state.
Now.
I didn't like that she was a
professional politician because I think
when you're a professional politician,
then you're dedicated to just winning
and not,
you know.
But I don't choose a higher,
I don't know.
I think problems,
but who the fuck wants to be president?
That's the other problem.
Like who the people who want to be
president don't understand.
It's the highest public service office
that you can possibly do.
Like you're also going to shit on.
The whole world's going to dump on your
head.
Yes.
And you have to act absolutely serve the
country later.
That's what I don't get.
I don't understand how anybody would
want to be president.
I want to give that much of themselves
up,
but I also can see how people would want
to aspire to,
to serve the country,
not lead the country,
serve the country.
That's where I just,
I lose my shit.
Like honestly,
so many of my friends I have,
I've tried to express this to them.
Then I can't have conversations with
them on twitter anymore.
I have to talk to them via text like I
can because yeah,
because people jump into my car,
I kid,
you know,
and it just,
I got so many rape threats during this
fucking election because I was,
oh my God,
it was insane.
It was just to the point where she was
like,
okay,
I can't speak with this person who's
arguing with me,
even though they're my friend and I'm
not unfriending them not,
not being their friend.
I'm just like,
you have to talk to me one on one
because so many people were just coming
at me and he's having a conversation in
a mall and people just walk by and start
yelling at you.
Okay,
good luck.
I know what,
what do you do with that?
And I'm okay with understanding like
that kind of,
I guess that kind of,
it's not an assault,
it's,
it's a word indicating.
So I meant,
but I've been not a public figure
necessarily,
but I've had people talk shit about me
to my face,
Talk Shit about me here and there
because of my previous group.
Because you know,
in mma you get a certain amount of
people just telling you how terrible you
are.
[inaudible] to a certain extent,
you don't.
Also,
you want to be desensitized to somebody
to threatening to rape you.
You don't want to be deceptive.
You never want that to be,
it's a terrible thing.
It's a horrible thing.
So fucking easy to say something and
just type it out,
try to get them,
I get Julie's fucking go and yeah,
and,
and when I'm looking for a fight,
I jumped right on it because I want to
fight him,
you know?
Why do you want to do that though?
I Miss Combat.
Really.
I miss arguing with people.
I do.
I like arguing with my fists or argue.
I Miss Combat.
I do miss that.
Like I thought about like maybe entering
grappling competitions might,
you know,
with that I actually,
Iowa hasn't really good Brazilian
Jujitsu club and I went there once and I
had a great time rolling.
And then I just,
I don't know what it is about the way my
mentality works,
but I feel like it would distract me
away from my writing.
And I know I wouldn't,
I know it would probably be balancing me
more,
but I get so intense about the things
that I'm doing.
Like I had a list of questions for you
today just because I wanted to find out
what you think about certain things like
as you get,
so,
uh,
I narrow minded maybe as a thing for it,
but I just get so obsessed about getting
answers to certain things or asking
questions about things.
Now I'm afraid I'd do that with
grappling and Jujitsu and I would get
too far into that and not address the
new direction that my life needs to take
a lot like me.
Well,
I'm a terrible standup comedian,
so you're,
you're nothing like your,
you're good.
You're a need to like get completely
absorbed and it's,
and then you're worried about being
absorbed and other things.
I do.
And it's like,
it's a weird,
it's,
I got sort of diagnosed when I went
through my depression spelling.
I'd been,
I'd had depression before,
but you know,
post fight depression was pretty rough.
And,
um,
you know,
I was on this,
I was on that and my body was like
getting all weird and um,
they said that I have real attention
deficit disorder problems and still
going through the testing for that.
But they did give me adderall,
which is amazing.
Amazing,
dangerous.
Very dangerous.
I know.
It sounds like it calmed me down so
much.
I was so calm and I was like,
oh,
we're all calmed you down.
Yes.
That's what they say about the people
that have adhd.
It's just like,
oh,
okay,
this makes a lot more sense.
I'm not looking at 10,000
things at once.
Right.
Like,
cause I couldn't run a 10,000
things at once.
Actually.
It's something I did talk to my
therapist and I was just like,
what am I going to lose creativity this
way?
Like I'm not going to you on still on
the antidepressants.
No,
no.
I went off of them when I started
school.
Um,
they mess with your sex life a little
bit.
I don't have an active one anymore,
so it doesn't matter.
But you know,
just a,
it was like you can't,
for me it was like,
it was really hard for me to reach
orgasm and stuff when I was hauling
them.
I know we're talking everything.
I try not to bash and I know I shit my
pants.
I couldn't orgasm for a year.
Yeah,
about,
I think it was rough.
It was rough,
but I was also so sad like,
you know,
like I dunno,
but now that I'm off of them,
I've also mid thirties so sex is
awesome.
Like as a woman and you're like,
I turned,
I turned 36 on Saturday and I'm just
like,
I've never been in a happier,
which is weird because you think,
okay,
well my fertility is dwayne dwindling.
I may not have kids,
I may have kids who knows what's going
to happen,
but sex as a woman in your mid thirties
is awesome.
Now I know so much better.
Yeah.
Now you know like,
yeah,
I mean I'm sure that's something that
would keep you up at night.
What does a woman that it's,
I can't believe I'm talking about this,
but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It's,
it's real life and real bodies and you
know,
people go through things.
And antidepressants really messed me up
for,
for men as well.
Yeah,
it was,
it was tough,
but it was needed.
I,
I didn't,
I didn't want to hurt myself anymore and
I think that I was going down a path
where I was going be hurting myself.
So yeah,
with your decisions,
with the mindset,
just physically,
like I have a history of eating
disorders and doing things and it's like
I could see myself slipping into that
path again.
And so it was like leaving,
fighting and then discovering that I
actually really want to explore this new
area of fighting that is writing or this
new area of creativity that is writing
that you can bring fighting into.
And um,
I needed all of these kinds of things to
be laid out and I thought I probably
would have interrupted myself if I
hadn't gone on antidepressants and I
hadn't kind of pulled back a little bit
from feeling everything so intensely.
And were you worried that you were
worthy?
The adderall was going to invade your
creative thoughts.
And
I'm,
I'm worried about that now.
I'm still being tech.
They put me on it,
but they said we have to go through all
this testing for it.
So I'm still being tested for if I have
attention deficit disorder or what or
whatever it is.
Um,
that makes me think in a peculiar way or
not be able to get tasks finished.
And so,
you know,
we're,
I'm still being tested for it,
but you know,
taking it now I am able to,
I'm able to calm down any ticket once a
day,
but it only lasts four hours.
So my doctor gave me an f for two a day.
I've only taken one today and it was
hours.
I've been drinking a shit load of
coffee,
but I took one like earlier this
morning.
But that was,
what does it do?
Like what's the effect?
So if say I wake up in,
in,
in my room and I look and it's messy in
my room,
um,
what I tend to do or my tendency to do,
especially post fighting whenever,
why we entered this weird mindspace is
panic about this is messy here.
This being messy here means I won't be
able to complete this task,
this will happen here,
this'll happen here.
And then I'm never going to meet.
And then I just get paralyzed and I
panic and I'm fearful that I can't
actually just get out of bed to put a
shirt on or to pick something up because
everything,
all of a sudden clouds in at once.
And,
um,
it would lead me to hyperfocus on really
strange things.
And I think that actually helped with
fighting if that's what I have.
I'm still in the diagnosis,
like process of this.
But you know,
so far this is the medicine that's
worked the best for me.
But,
um,
when,
when I was fighting,
one thing that I did do poorly was I
would go from a to c instead of go to a
to b to c,
I would see what would happen after I
won the fight.
In my mind when I first started training
camp,
which a lot of fighters do and I think
that helps,
but sometimes you miss b where the
actual fight happens and in my mind
sometimes I would gloss over that and I
would get caught up in things and I
would wait for this to happen and wait
for that time or be paralyzed and not be
able to make the next step.
Right now I feel like I am able to,
when I take a pill,
I'm able to put my feet on the ground
out of bed,
look up and say,
okay,
my room needs to be cleaned,
but first I need to do this and I'm able
to make,
I'm able to go to a to B and then do z
instead of just jumping over and then
looking at sea and then thinking all of
the things after me just come crashing
at me and I freak out.
Now you said earlier that post career I
started thinking about brain trauma.
Yeah,
I started thinking about do you do what?
Like what thoughts specifically
I wondered about well the depression.
Right,
right.
You know,
and I wonder about how many shots that
I've taken.
I mean they had a good chin.
I was rocked a lot in the gym.
I sparred a lot.
I mean I,
you know,
like I say,
I like back in the old days I would
fight whatever opportunity came my way.
Never took,
had,
didn't have ct scans till I got into
strike force,
which was late in my career.
So,
or a ct or MRI,
I forgot which one does what.
So I don't know how much of um,
the dizziness that I have is like,
yeah,
just like a little here,
here,
you know.
That's right.
You know,
like not like not finding my sunglasses
because were on the top of my head and
wandering around looking for them.
And for a while there I was really
scared.
Maybe this is a post fight,
you know,
brain trauma and,
and,
and the depression set in pretty hard
post fight.
So I was wondering,
well,
what,
you know,
and,
and seeing doctors and stuff like that.
Like,
you know,
I,
they were like,
you know,
maybe you should get an Mri,
maybe we shoot your brain checked,
but let's also address the depression
right now.
And once the depression was addressed
and I was able to see that there's
something else going on here that may
not be,
um,
due to getting hit in the head,
it may actually be due to me having a
chemical thing that makes me just all
over the place because I'm in the best
school in the world for writing right
now.
I didn't get in there like without I a
how to explain it.
The focus is different.
I think I just needed to channel it and
I think that I got very scared that I
had brain damage,
that I was going to never be able to do
anything but I wasn't going to win.
And the truth was I think that my body
chemistry had changed somewhat and my
learning disassociated or my learning,
whatever it is,
that that made me good at fighting had
to translate into a different world.
And so I had to kind of take steps to do
that and get into some pretty intense
therapy and do things like that in order
to understand that no,
my brain is just wired differently.
So a,
I don't know if it's the creative brain
or the obsessive rain or whatever.
Yeah,
it's,
um,
I mean I sound like I'm talking bro
Science here because they really don't
have my diagnosis sheet to show you from
an actual doctor.
And not only that,
they're,
the reality of depression is that a
doctor can't really say like,
Oh hey look,
you've got herpes.
There it is.
Right,
right.
You know what I mean?
It's not something like that.
It's depression is some very,
very difficult thing to define and you
only know whether or not you have it
yourself.
They can't like scan you and go,
oh Julia and depressed.
You can answer a whole bunch of
questions.
Right.
Did they give you,
but you can also lie if you know what
they're looking for,
which is what I did in many depression
tests.
I would just lie,
cause I didn't want people to think I
had depression and it was just like,
okay,
but I am actually feeling this on this
survey.
I should answer this correctly.
And I,
I will say that,
uh,
something that I did,
you know,
when I look back at my lifetime of
choices and thinks that he did,
I self medicated with experiences like
trying to have this experience,
this experience,
isn't it,
have all of this,
all of this,
do this,
do you know all of this?
And I sold Medicare.
I had very severe bulemia Yep.
That would calm me down.
It,
we call me down.
No,
I'm the early,
early days of fighting.
It's actually one of the things I
really,
and I don't talk about it,
but I really credit Greg Jackson for
this and putting me on a pad because I
confessed to him,
okay,
this is a problem that I have when I
first seen him that this is something
that I've,
I've dealt with a little bit with some
treatments,
but you know,
I puked my,
my food up and he,
he didn't let me any more.
I don't know how to explain.
You didn't let me anywhere,
but he just,
he put a lot of care and pressure on me
to be a more mentally healthy person by
directing that energy,
that panicked energy when we get all
worked up and just have to go puke
because I didn't know what else to do
with myself.
And he helped me direct that energy into
the sport and he gave me tasks to do and
I ended up working for him,
but it was just like him.
He's really fucking good dude.
Like it really good dude.
And yeah,
and,
and just,
you know,
I would,
I honestly credit him for,
I think he saved my life to a certain
extent because I got pretty bad there
for a while.
Like,
and um,
when I moved to Jackson's it was like
sort of that understanding that I'm
stepping into a new realm where I am a
professional athlete now I have to
conduct myself a certain way.
I have to eat food a certain way.
I have to address my body's or we have
to,
you know,
it,
it took a burden off of me that made me
panic.
And I don't know how to explain that to
give me purpose.
Maybe to be somebody that's somebody
else's invested in to understand,
okay.
He's like,
you know,
you're my first female MMA fighter that
I really want to put work into,
so don't get fucking pregnant.
Don't do this,
don't puke anymore.
Don't do that.
You know,
usually we put some rules in place for
me when I came there because he said he
wasn't really on board with him.
Oh,
I shouldn't say that because I always
get him a lot of shit.
He was on board with female mma and
then,
you know,
he saw my carano fight,
he liked it and he liked me and he was
just like,
okay,
I'll give this a shot.
And for me it saved my life because I
don't know where I would be without mma.
Um,
for,
you know,
and when it comes to,
I guess the bulemia and the,
the self sabotage that I was doing to
myself competing in the sport and,
and finding purpose,
it was really important.
And just the talks I would have with him
about like,
you know,
philosophy and this kind of thing.
Cause it's,
it's hard to find people to talk about
some intellectual subjects with
sometimes in that sport or antigen.
Yeah.
And so to be able to sit down and break
things down and think,
okay,
I can use my brain this way,
this is great.
And then when I quit fighting and I
moved to Kansas,
I didn't have that bubble anymore.
I didn't have that,
that home or that,
that feeling.
Right.
You know?
And so it was just like I just slid
right backwards and I was gaining all
this weight and I was,
you know,
I just became very eating poorly.
Oh yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I mean you,
sugar is so addictive when you actually
get to eat it again.
Like what do you do?
Like it's,
it feels so good.
Like,
so yeah,
I went through a rough time there and
then I,
I found school and I was like,
Oh shit,
I can do this.
This is where my energy can be.
So
well,
that's awesome that you found something.
I mean,
I would really think that diet would
have also a pretty significant effect on
the way your brain works.
Oh,
you have to,
do you monitor that now?
Do you take care of yourself now?
Yes.
Because I actually,
I'm,
I mean I still,
I'll drink sugar.
Like I'll put sugar in a drink or
something like that,
but I don't,
I don't care for it as much.
My,
my tastes have kind of changed over
time.
I like vegetables.
I like meat.
I,
you know,
vegetables and meat were a huge staple
when I was fighting.
And now when I find myself just being
drawn to that anyway,
you know,
and,
but,
you know,
post fighting,
it's like,
it's the orgy of sugar in things you
were never allowed to have.
And Yeah.
And it's like,
well,
you weren't,
body reasoning wasn't designed to eat
this anyway,
so it's going to affect your brain to
just give yourself like a cheat day or
award day or some point that what I
don't do is,
um,
and this could come from a lifetime of
Catholicism.
Like I don't,
yeah,
I know,
right?
Yeah.
But no,
I,
I grew up very Catholic.
I'm very not Catholic now.
Don't tell my grandma.
Um,
no,
but what I don't do is I don't beat
myself up.
If I eat junk food,
fine.
Okay.
But the next meal is going to be healthy
like,
so you're more concerned with overall
health,
mental,
physical,
the whole thing.
And to be obsessive about something,
it's actually probably worse than just
having a little sugar.
Yes.
And,
and I guess when it to be,
yeah,
because then it's self flagellation
right.
Then you're just like,
Oh fuck,
oh,
I just not everything is terrible.
I'm just going to eat this terrible
person.
Yeah,
exactly.
It just goes down that spiral and it's
kind of dumb and I realized that I need
something to be obsessive about and that
has actually come through writing,
you know,
and that sort of thing.
And,
and,
and working towards like I'd love to
write the great book,
just the book I'm working on it
of thinking that you have with lend
itself towards something like that.
So obsessive style thinking like you
could really be an amazing tool for you.
I would hope so.
I hope.
And I it just,
I guess translating mma to people,
not just in the,
I think so.
It's a,
when I first came,
I came into,
I was just,
no,
I'm done with them a man,
I'm not gonna,
you know,
and then I'm just like,
oh,
but these are my people.
Like even,
okay.
What about your,
just your life experiences itself?
I mean,
coming from a point of view of someone
like you is so smart and articulate,
I would imagine that your memoirs or
what you would be able to describe about
your,
your days competing,
it would be really fascinating and
compelling.
Yeah,
I've definitely worked on that.
Like I've written some things to that
extent.
Um,
the stuff that they picked up for sports
illustrated was really nice.
Like that,
that was nice.
That was a,
that was a help.
Um,
I like things to be on a little bit.
It gets a little bit,
and not woo woo like literary level,
but just,
it's something that's,
um,
I'd like symbol a little bit more
symbolism,
a little bit more.
Um,
I dunno when I wrote the piece about
Chi,
it's the piece that got me into Iowa.
It was the piece about cutting weight
when I decided to retire and when I cut
weight and I was in Australia and I saw
this painting and it just changed
everything and I was just like,
wow.
Um,
it's uh,
oh,
it's,
it's since it's a picasso painting of
this woman with a hat on her head,
um,
a Dutch hat,
it's um,
oh God.
Um,
and as well,
um,
I cannot remember the name of it.
I'm drawing a blank right here.
Eggs.
Think about eggs.
I think about eggs,
how eggs are prepared,
poached,
scramble and keep going.
Keep going.
Hollandaise,
uh,
was Moselle holidays.
He has something to that effect.
I believe I have the print in my room,
but now I just,
I don't look at the titles of things.
I just did the images more than
anything.
And I saw this painting and I was in a
museum in Australia and I was cutting
weight for my fight.
I had all my sweats on,
but I was in an art museum and I saw it
and I just,
I felt like it was talking to me all of
a sudden and I was just like delirious.
Cause you were losing weight.
No,
but symbolically I know what you mean.
Like the symbolism there.
Like I was,
I was talking to myself.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the painting.
Yeah.
And I just looked at that and yeah,
Labelle,
Hollandaise,
that's it.
Not memo sauce.
I suck at names.
Um,
that's another,
I have a very bad memory,
but I,
you know,
I looked at that and I just,
I connected with this painting and this
weird,
weird way.
I just saw it and I couldn't stop
talking to it in my head.
Like,
like there's this a person I'm talking
to you now and it just,
and I wrote about this for it.
It was just like,
you know,
she's like,
Oh yeah,
you know what I'm done.
And I knew that in that museum,
just standing there looking at this
painting before my fight.
Well,
you sure you weren't just looking for a
sign.
Of course I was.
And it was just this beautiful image of
this woman who's,
you know,
it doesn't look like a fighter.
It doesn't look at anything to do with
combat is just a naked woman wearing a
hat.
But all of a sudden it just,
to me,
that was what I was looking for.
I was looking for that sort of sign and
that's where it became cohesive.
Like that's that moment.
And um,
I just knew I was done.
That's fascinating.
I think I'd been looking for excuses for
a long time before that.
And I think I wanted to retire before I
fought Jermaine Duran to me,
you know,
like I,
I,
I was just so tired and I was just so,
my mind just wasn't going that direction
that other fighters,
you see that moment where you know that
they're just sort of phoning it in and
they can't figure out how to get off.
And for me it was like,
I would overtrain like before the
Jermaine photos,
so overtrained and I was so tired and
it's just like froze,
you know,
and stuff like that.
And I'll also,
she hit like a fucking mack truck,
but like she put me out on my feet in
the third round it up,
fight.
Like she hit me with two right singer
right hand.
I didn't know what was going on.
Like I was,
what did you think about her fight with
holly?
So,
um,
I think it was terrible.
Horrible.
It was terrible.
I think that should have been called and
that should have been appointed acted.
And I don't mean that as an insult to
Jermaine or anything like that,
that's combat minded or whatever.
But that's cheating.
Like 100% shooting and shit.
Yeah,
he was one of those shots and I think
it's,
yeah,
I think it's something that she saw that
she could do.
And she did.
They're disappointed when they didn't.
They denied her protest.
Yeah,
me too.
I've protest.
That was a very legitimate honor.
That's not something in the hall has
ever done before.
No,
she's not.
she's,
and it's not like she doesn't accept a
feat.
I mean,
she doesn't accept defeat as I will keep
moving forward,
but she's,
she wasn't,
she doesn't find excuses.
I've known that woman for almost a
decade.
She doesn't look for excuses.
She looks for ways to improve and yeah,
so that,
you know,
hurt putting a protest in is very
legitimate,
very legitimate.
And the Holly Holmes another one,
she's all heart.
I mean she came back from a deficit and
that fight landed that,
that um,
question mark kick over the shoulder.
That was beautiful.
That was one of the best question mark
kicks I've ever seen landed inside the
octagon against a really tricky Moitai
opponent who was getting the better of
her early on.
Holly is,
I feel like the world hasn't even seen
the best Holly Holm yet.
Um,
I know that sounds weird,
but she's 36,
right?
35.
I think that there's more to her though.
Potential.
Why is that?
That we haven't even seen yet.
But we'll see.
Like if that is going to,
I don't know what her plant,
I don't talk,
there's not a company we're talking
about with The v tour thing though that
it's almost like your,
your experience and your,
your ability and your knowledge gets
overwhelmed by father time.
It's like father time and they come,
there's a cross in the road and you have
to figure out like how much experience
do you have,
how much knowledge and whether or not
your body can actually act on those
things anymore.
And then it comes a point where they're
just
I,
yeah.
And I don't know,
uh,
I'd say that's pretty early to say about
her in her mma career,
but she has had all that boxing and
kickboxing experience before this maybe,
you know,
she has like,
ah Gosh,
she's so inspirational.
And she finds that she lost that one
boxing match.
[inaudible] was so hard to watch.
Brutal and,
and the ref not horrible.
They should have stopped that fight.
Oh my God.
I know.
And her mentality coming out of that
fight,
I had to be her sparring partner after
that fight.
If that tells you which brand image I
might have now.
But no,
I bet her mentality of not,
she refused to interact with people or
have people corner heard that would
doubt that she could win that fight in
the future refused.
She,
she,
she is such a champion mind that no,
if people thought she would,
that she would take corrections,
she would take,
you know,
this,
I'm going to switch this,
this up.
I've got to do this differently.
But if you believe that she shouldn't
have the rematch,
she wouldn't work with you.
Yeah.
Because she was like,
no,
I can't have somebody not believing in
me.
I mean it was,
it was incredible.
It was very inspiration.
Yeah.
Did,
oh my gosh.
Yeah.
No,
she's a warrior.
No doubt about that.
Yeah.
So we only have a couple more minutes.
I've been talking so much.
I'm sorry you had a bunch of questions.
You still throw some months because I
know you've got them written down.
It
was the,
I think when we went back to the,
and these are,
you know,
it's the shorthand,
but it was,
you know,
the who,
where are you when you started and who
are you now?
And I guess what goes with that,
and I ask these questions because I've
been asking them,
a lot of people in the sport or in this
industry are people who are high level
in what they're doing.
What,
what would you have left behind?
Like what,
what do you regret?
What would you have left behind in
becoming who you are now?
What could you have changed?
And I don't need to,
it's a hard question to ask because
nobody wants to look baton rouge.
Oh I regret this because we learned from
our regrets.
Right?
But if there's,
you could,
if you
could have changed,
you could have done differently.
Would you have,
I think all of my errors of made me a
better person.
So I don't think they're bad.
You know?
I think you mean that's a real cliche
thing.
You don't,
you don't make mistakes or you,
if you do make mistakes,
you learn.
If you don't make mistakes,
you grow and you improve.
I mean like it's all good.
If you look,
it's,
it's not what happens.
It's how you react to what happened
and what one mistake do you think like
really defined you to make you better?
Oh Geez.
Not One.
It's just a bunch of them.
I mean,
God,
there's a million of them.
There's nowhere to even start.
You know what I mean?
You're just constantly make mistakes.
You make mistakes with your friends and
make mistakes with the people you're
involved with romantically you mixed
mistakes careerwise and make mistakes
with comedy and art,
you're constantly,
it's a constant process of mistakes,
you know?
Especially when you're writing new stuff
with Jujitsu,
there's constant mistakes,
you know what I mean?
I think testing yourself and constantly
seeking improvement and constantly
trying to expand upon your creative work
and expand upon,
you know,
what,
what you're,
what you're doing as a martial artist or
what you're doing as an athlete or what,
you know,
improving upon your,
your conditioning drills and trying to
advance in Yoga,
get better at that.
And I just,
I'm always doing something that I'm
failing in.
I mean,
I think that's a big part of it.
I like doing new things and socking at
them.
Yeah,
I think that's good too.
What,
so in that,
in that vein,
I guess of reasoning,
what do you carry into this like,
I mean,
I don't know the exact numbers of your
podcast,
but it's huge,
right?
Like I mean you get huge amount of
downloads.
I'm your number one or in the top at
least the top five all the time for you
know,
whatever pot.
But,
so what do you carry into this space
with people that you don't want to leave
behind?
Like what is it that you think you bring
to this that I don't want to leave
behind like that.
Do you carried since you were young,
since you first started in the
entertainment industry or an in mma or
in Jujitsu,
what part of Joe do you bring into this
space and that you continue to bring
that?
I definitely don't think about that,
but if there was anything it would be
genuine curiosity I have,
I've genuinely curious about things and
I'm trying to make this as entertaining
as possible.
So I do my best to try to make the
conversation flow as,
and I don't always succeed.
I fail all the time and that failure
makes me try better.
I definitely think I'm better at
podcasting now than I was six months ago
and better six months ago then it was a
year ago and then I hope I'll be better
a year from now that I am today and
that's just
beck is fail,
fail,
fail better all the
time.
But there's also,
this isn't in a weird way,
it's an audio art form and it doesn't
seem like it is,
but the art of conversation is there's
a,
there's an art,
there's an interaction to it and you're
very good at it,
which is one of the reasons why you
apologize when you accidentally talk
over each other.
But that's a part of human interaction.
We talk over each other,
we accidentally do or sometimes you have
a point that you feel like you have to
get in now or just forget it.
I mean and it's,
it's a matter of like how to do it the
right way.
And one of the things that I've found
from doing podcasts is how bad are at
that.
It's really frustrating to talk to
really a self centered people that just
talk over everyone and don't listen to
what anybody has to say and aren't
genuinely listening.
They're just waiting for their chain to
talk.
I mean that,
that is really frustrating and it's,
you realize the art of conversation is
something that's cultivated.
It's something that you,
you have to work on.
And there are a lot of people just
don't,
they're not good at it
cause you have to,
you have to be aware that you're weaving
something into a bigger picture as
opposed to yeah.
As opposed to just saying what you're
saying and then walking out.
Yeah.
Listening is huge.
I think you're a very good listener and
I think that that's like,
that's what I see from the outside that
you're able to do well.
And I'd love to emulate you as a,
as a commentator in that sense,
and you is creating this space.
I,
I'd love to,
to model a certain amount of myself
after that because I think it's
wonderful.
But,
um,
so I mean,
any huge regrets,
not meaning you don't have to share
them,
but any,
does anything keep you up at night?
No.
I mean,
if,
uh,
there's many things in my life that if
they were presented in front of me right
now learning that I've done them in the
past and fucked up,
I would do it differently.
But that's part of being who you are
today.
I think people,
that word regret is a very dangerous
word because people far too often define
themselves by their past failures.
Instead of saying that that's not you.
Like you're not that person.
You're you right now.
And that's what I really truly believe.
I believe that you are all of your
experiences and in life and all of the
data that you've acquired and all the
revelations and understandings that
we've gathered up because of those
positive and negative experiences.
And that creates who you are at this
moment.
And the most interesting people to me
are the people that have been tested,
that have gone through trials and
tribulations.
And it's one of the reasons why fighters
are so interesting because the emotional
rollercoaster of a fight camp and then
fighting and competing and not just an
mma,
but people that do Jujitsu and uh,
boxers and just people that have done
something that's very difficult to do.
You've tested yourself in a way that
very few people have.
And so you understand yourself in a much
deeper way.
You understand where that breaking point
is.
You understand what happens when you
break.
You understand who the demons are and
your mind to tell you to break.
You know,
and some people never meet those demons
and they're there.
They're waiting,
they're waiting for the call.
They're waiting for that fucking button
to be pushed so they can pop up into
your brain and wreck havoc.
Yeah.
Some people just want to fight those
demons and the family,
they make them up.
Sure.
They make their own demons up.
They create problems,
they create stress.
And you know,
sometimes they invoke those demons.
They asked those demons to come in and
distract them from all the real issues
that they have in their life and all the
things that they actually do need to
deal with.
All the real work that the pain of the
mundane,
the f,
the pain of the boring discipline work
is sometimes so great that people does
mean.
That's why some providers wind up
fucking off and getting drunk and never
coming to,
to work out and wind up being in poor
shape and the fight comes off.
It's not because they didn't know the
fight was coming.
He's not the cause.
There are a coward.
It's because they're,
they're letting their demons trip them
up.
I think boredom and that not listening
aspect.
I think that it's also connected.
Um,
no.
You,
yeah,
and that leads people down paths where
they can't get back from it.
Sure.
Unfortunate.
That's a,
yeah.
I think when we lament the loss of
somebody who's potential,
it's not always because they were doing
the wrong things or they lost the wrong
fight,
but it's because they never recognized
where they can move on from there.
Yeah.
And exploring that.
Your personal sovereignty,
exploring your ability to truly manage
all of these very difficult scenarios
that present themselves in life is one
of the most interesting and fascinating
things about studying human beings.
And to me it's like the exact opposite
of the mob mentality when you're swept
away in this group think and you're
really not responsible for yourself and
your thinking and it's very almost
selfish way of giving into this thing.
It's too easy.
There's so many people around.
Ah,
just go crazy.
I was like the opposite of like the
lone,
one of the reasons why I didn't never
really was into team sports.
I was like,
I understand that it's a challenge.
I understand that it's difficult,
but there's an intensity of the one on
one competition that cannot be matched
in any other forum.
Whether it's even,
it's one on one playing tennis.
It's so much more intense than a group
game of volleyball or basketball or
whatever.
I would say to that though,
given because you are who you are and
you've built so many quote unquote
followers,
he built so many people who listen to
your opinion.
You are in a sense on a team and you are
a leader because so many people download
your podcast.
So many people want to enter this space
that you create.
So do you feel a responsibility to them
to tell them to think for themselves?
Okay.
Hope people just figure that out on
their own because there's no way anybody
could think for you.
Right,
right,
right.
But I do allow people to think for me in
a certain way.
Like when I listen to someone,
like if I listened to a book on tape,
um,
or I listen to a lecture,
what I'm listening to is I'm allowing
this person to direct my thoughts with
their words,
their painting pictures.
They're explaining facts,
they're going over their own personal
experiences.
And you are in many ways allowing that
person to think for you.
But then when that's over,
you think for yourself and you take into
account what that person has said and it
can enhance your perceptions.
Because if someone's being honest with
you,
which I think is one of the most
important parts of being,
of expressing yourself,
I would like to know what your real
motivations are.
I want to know what your real thoughts
are.
I don't want you to pretend,
I don't want you to be a politician.
I don't want you to just give me some
bullshit version of who you are because
you think I'm going to like you more
from that.
And I think people can tell when
someone's doing that,
right?
And I think when someone's not doing
that,
when someone's being genuine,
people cling to it and they go,
look,
maybe he doesn't know what the fuck he's
doing,
but maybe he's being honest about it and
I'll find out together.
We'll figure it out together.
Because at least this dude's telling me
the truth,
or she's telling me the truth.
Or,
you know,
this group,
an honest group.
That's what I think we belong for in
this life because this is,
life is so filled with joy,
dramatic interpretations of reality and
yeah,
and so there's so much just bullshit,
but it's,
it's hard to find truth and we seek
truth,
I think.
I think truth is sought in combat.
I think there's a lot of people that
seek truth and watching mma,
like when we're talking about that
Darren Elkins fight,
there's no truer moment in the world and
this guy digging deep and find me.
It's as raw as it gets.
His face is covered in blood.
He can't even fucking see that's a,
there's a truth in that.
That's an escapable.
You can't dance your way out of it.
You can't bullshit your way out of him.
Spotlights and glitter and fucking hype
music desk.
There's none of that.
It's a,
it's,
it's down to this,
this inescapable reality.
And I think when people are confronted
with all the trials and tribulations of
life and there's so much confusion and
we seek inspiration in so many different
avenues and we seek leadership and we
seek mentorship.
And we seek like this,
this hope,
hopefully this light out there that
guides us in some sort of a way and one
of the only ways that we can really
truly trust that light as if we know
it's coming from a person that has
committed to the path of honesty.
Right,
right.
So what are your tools for discernment
in that?
Just don't bullshit myself.
Yeah,
it's really,
manipulation is so easy to fall into it.
It's also so easy to,
to just resent everybody about then too,
like yeah,
I teach rhetoric,
so like we,
we consider a text and we're just like,
okay,
who's the speaker?
What is the text?
What is,
you know,
what is the message in the tax?
Like what are they trying to say?
And then what is this huge like myths
surrounding all of them.
What are they trying to do here?
And it's,
it's so interesting to see kids' minds
change about like,
oh,
I don't actually have to believe this
because this is what I've been assigned,
or I do have to think a certain way or I
have to consider the source.
I begin gets it's kind of a rabbit hole
sometimes.
Yes.
You know,
that's where in my mind,
like the true was religion to me.
Like,
or whatever you want to call religion
is,
is it's science.
I just think science is that the,
um,
the scientific method is based on so
much philosophy so much and it's trying
to fail all the time.
Like that's what he's,
he's like repeatable results.
If you can't get repeatable like
results,
like blind results on something,
then that's what you're always trying to
do and you're always failing.
But you know,
I come from a family scientists,
so of course,
like that's a,
you know,
for me it's just,
it's what I love more than anything is
to,
to hear them talk about how to find
truth.
And then truth is also different from
fact.
And so when you go down,
Kay,
is it truth or is it fact or is it a
painting?
Like what's going on here?
It gets really,
I'm finding tools for discernment.
That's really,
that becomes really tricky and I think
that's where a hive mine comes from.
Right.
You know,
like people not trying to grab those
tools,
not trying to assess their own
motivations for latching on to thinking
that this is right.
Right.
Yeah.
They just want their team to win.
And it's also absorbing information and
sort of formulating your own viewpoint
takes time.
It takes a long time.
And who you are today is going to be
different than who you are 10 years from
now.
And that's something that you'd have to
kind of embrace and you know,
be be,
it's,
it's hard to think it in the moment,
but be happy for those uncomfortable
moments.
Yeah.
Cause those uncomfortable moments or
that you learned from,
yeah,
you have to be wrong.
You have to seek being wrong as much as
possible.
Right.
And you have to see things that maybe
change the way you look at things and
experienced things,
change your,
your boundaries,
change your perceptions.
One of the things I worry the most for,
I think as a country for us that we get
so comfortable that,
oh,
we're soft as fuck.
And you know,
and I don't even mean,
I don't even mean soft as in like puppy
shit in a plastic bag just because I
don't know what it is about like,
and it's,
it's again,
I do believe what you said about
individualism and doing your own thing
and striking,
you know,
forging your own path and stuff like
that.
But our inability somehow to,
um,
to commit ourselves to learning.
Yeah.
But it's not everybody.
A lot of with car,
you're committed to learning.
I'm committed to learning and that's a
lot of people listening to this,
to the committed to learn.
Yeah.
I hope so.
Like I,
I'm,
I'm banking on that because I actually
believe in people.
Like I believe that people are good.
I believe you believe that.
I think the group
think thing is,
is real.
And what you're talking about is real.
But I also think that when,
when you're judging 350 million people,
it's impossible to generalize,
right?
When you say as a country we're soft,
we're getting our shit.
Yeah,
we're soft,
we're right.
A lot of us are.
If you look overall,
if you looked at the pie chart of soft
people,
I go,
oh fuck.
Look how soft we are through the Pi part
of pie chart of ignorant people.
Yo,
look how ignorant we are.
But in that pie chart,
in defining people and that sort of a
broad generalization,
you,
you lose the beauty of individuality.
And that's one of the things that's
unique about us is that we have the
ability in this country to to seek out
all sorts of different paths to be who
you would choose to be,
to follow whatever occupation or
whatever path of interest that you
choose to follow.
And I think that's,
that's a beautiful thing.
It's an amazing thing.
It is a beautiful thing.
I don't think those opportunities are
available to everybody in a lot of
senses.
And that's just through my own
experience of becoming a fighter and
having to struggle to be a female
fighter,
you know,
that makes me think of,
I'm actually privileged to have been
able to make that decision.
And you know,
the,
the female fighters after me,
I think benefit from me making the
decision and from other fighters like me
making that decision because sure,
it's moved on.
But I do think that when we look at
society and we talk about,
I don't know,
being soft or not being soft at,
sometimes people just,
they can't pull themselves up from their
bootstraps if they don't know where the
fuck their boots are or where they
trained them.
Well,
like,
and I do think there's so many,
there's so much divisiveness and I think
that's what leads to,
and I'm,
I'm a fucking perpetuate or of that.
Like when I go off on,
you know,
this fucking Maggot guys and this and
that,
you know,
I go nuts sometimes I,
I fall into that anger and I wish I
didn't,
but then don't,
well that's what,
that's what therapies for it.
Right.
I like a good fight.
I do.
Oh,
would
say to you as a friend that I think
you'd probably be better off expressing
that aggressive energy in some sort of
another outlet.
I believe you end up interacting with
strangers because another thing about
some of those people that you're
interacting with are fucking losers and
they will lock onto you and they find
out that you are a source of
entertainment where they could press
your buttons and make you dance and
they'll,
they'll keep doing it.
And that's what trolling is all about.
It is a phenomenal art form.
This trolling that they've taken.
I mean it's,
it's great.
I mean the best thing I've ever
discovered is my mute button.
Not even blocking people but just muting
people.
And also,
I mean actually the best thing I've
discovered is that like I have to take
my phone and physically put it away from
me and then I can write and I get into
that zone and it feels wonderful and
it's just like putting the phone away
and just putting it down,
disconnecting.
But you don't want to be,
I want to connect with people.
I love that twitter has done it's big
great friendships from it.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
one of the beautiful things about doing
podcasts,
one of the things it's taught me is that
I don't ever have three hour
conversations with people outside of
podcasting.
Like you and I got deeper and got to
know each other better and this
conversation then we would,
if we knew each other,
passing each other with the UFC for a
decade.
How has it been?
Three hours?
Yes.
Holy Shit.
I had no idea.
That's what we usually do.
I had no idea it was that long.
Time flies very.
You always have other guests and you
know,
all three hours,
you and I just,
but,
but we,
whenever in life do you get to sit
across from someone?
Just stare them in the eyes across the
table like you and I have done for three
hours and just go deep.
Well,
and it's a space you've created,
right?
Like you've built this pit,
you're big on that word.
Space creating.
I know writing shit.
I,
it's so weird.
It's like I was reading all this for
Carlton's Heterotopia Steph and I'm just
like,
this is really cool because I see this
when we read and I see this,
I listen to so many audio books and so
many podcasts and I'm just like,
I'm finding weird spaces in my brain to
be connected to people who don't even
know who the fuck I am.
But I feel close to them.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's,
yeah,
that's exactly what it is and that
sounds,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I,
I should probably stop talking,
but I forgot.
I totally forgot to plug in.
Victor.
I was just like,
cause I was gonna just,
I was going to email all of these
questions too.
Anyways,
I could talk to you,
but I love actually talking to in person
because I feel like I haven't had the
opportunity to actually know you and um,
you know,
except for when I listen to you,
but that's a different,
yeah,
yeah.
It's weird,
but life's weird.
Life is weird.
Where does fuck it's fucking weird.
Is it?
Is it,
is this all about
good for people to hear that it's weird
for other people too.
You know it's good for me to hear that.
It's weird for you and it's good for
other people to hear that.
It's weird for me and it's fucking
weird.
Yeah,
but you can be nice.
you can be nice through this.
Yeah,
you could be nice and you can actually,
you can connect to people and like if it
is like the Appalachian trail and we're
just putting one foot in front of the
other,
at least it's damn town.
Feel people that finish that trail think
that.
I don't think they do.
I think the people who fail,
they decide it's just one foot in front.
The other,
I want to stay at
the fucking red roof inn tonight.
Thank you very much.
Really appreciate you coming on here.
It was fun.
I really,
really enjoyed it.
All right folks,
we'll be back next week.
See Ya.